[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débat pour les élections législatives ce
soir nous accueillons autour de cette
table les 17 candidats qui souhaitent
devenir député pour la deuxième
circonscription est des yvelines
circonscriptions où environ 85 mille
électeurs seront appelés à voter lors du
premier tour le 11 juin prochain et qui
comprend les cantons de chevreuse vélizy
versailles sud et viroflay
pour des raisons pratiques nous
accueillerons les candidats en trois
séquences et pour ce premier débat nous
sommes en plateau avec pascal thévenot
député sortant et l'érudit marc soriano
candidat de la france insoumise yasmine
bnm mat pour le front national
jean-noël barrot au candidat modem
investi par la république en marche
quand guy roux et la rue l'en excuser
moi candidats écologistes soutenus par
le ps les verts et le parti communiste
et enfin pascale poirot candidat divers
droite soutenu par le parti chrétien
démocrate bonsoir à vous si ce alors je
précise évidemment que votons de paroles
seront chronométrés vous pourrez donc
échangé entre vous si vous le souhaitez
mais nous veillerons aussi à l'égalité
des temps de parole on débute ce débat
par un tour de table avec une première
question plutôt simple pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance ou vous refaire confiance le
11 juin prochain ont commencé avec vous
pascal thévenot député sortant pourquoi
doivent-ils vous refaire confiance
bah oui comme vous le dites j'ai eu la
chance qui m'est fait confiance il ya un
an et je pense qu'ils se sont rendus
compte que c'est important d'avoir un
chef d'entreprise trop peu nombreux à
dans la somme et nationales qui
puisqu'on est moins de dix industrielle
en fait à l'assemblée nationale est à la
fois qu'ils connaissent aussi son ce
terrain puisque en tant que maire j'ai
accès en direct toute la misère qu'on
peut avoir les accidents de la vie et
puis j'ai aussi la chance d'avoir
profité de cette circonscription puisque
j'y vis depuis 50 ans entre vélizy la
vallée de chevreuse et si tous les
maires ou plus quasiment tous les mêmes
se confond confiance c'est pas un hasard
marc soriano pour vous c'est une
première cette élection pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance
les autres leaders politiques comme
françois baron qui se dit d'une
opposition avec un premier ministre de
son parti enfin on ne comprends plus ce
qui se passe on ne sait plus qui est ma
chrono compatibles ou pas et en ce qui
me concerne et ce qui nous concerne à la
france insoumise nous sommes sur une
ligne claire nous ne nous trompons pas
les électeurs il n'y a pas de
carabistouilles nous sommes un endroit
précis de l'échiquier politique avec un
projet précis et je vois là je suis là
tout simplement pour pour porter cette
voie pour porter cette voie parce que
dans cette confusion ce qui va gagner à
la fin c'est l'extrême finances yassine
benzia mat pour le front national
pourquoi les acteurs doivent t'ils vous
faire confiance l'enjoint je suis une
candide est ancré sur le territoire est
ancré dans la réalité également puisque
en parallèle de mon mandat de
conseillère régionale d'île de france
je travaille dans le privé et je suis
mère de trois enfants et je peux vous le
dire d'être mère de trois enfants on est
toujours ramené à la réalité même si on
avait on pourrait s'échapper de temps en
temps donc voila et donc au front
national aussi nous sommes clairs sur
notre ligne politique a pas de
magouilles ou ou de retournement de
veste en fonction de là où le vent a
tourné
voilà donc je serai fidèle à mes
engagements jean-noël barrot
vous êtes candidat investi par la
république en marche pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance
votez pour la république en marche c'est
faire le choix du rassemblement au delà
des clivages partisans pour apporter des
solutions concrètes aux problèmes des
français
c'est aussi faire le choix du renouveau
de la la vie politique en france avec la
fin du cumul des mandats la fin de la
réserve parlementaire la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires l'évaluation
des politiques publiques et cette
évaluation j'y suis particulièrement
sensible puisque c'est le métier auquel
j'ai été formé et que j'ai exercées sur
le campus de hec à jouy-en-josas où j'ai
passé presque dix ans et où je retourne
à mes prochaines enfin donné
votez pour la république en marche s'est
donné une majorité claire au président
de la république pour lui donner une
chance de réussir tanguy ruelland on
poursuit avec vous pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que je suis ancré dans le
territoire javi de versailles sud
j'ai fait mes études juste en face à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines je suis devenu avocat au
barreau de versailles dont que je
connais très bien la circonscription
alors j'ai 34 ans mais j'ai toujours
vécu dans les yvelines est les
problématiques de transports notamment
les pratiques de terres agricoles qui
disparaissent c'est quelque chose sur
lequel je suis très sensible
ça c'est la première raison la seconde
raison c'est une raison de transparence
c'est-à-dire que les électeurs le
verrons dans ma profession de foi et je
me suis engagé à ce que ma remplaçante
soit aussi mon assistante parlementaire
si je suis élu je pense que aujourd'hui
il ya eu trop d'abus
on a vu que la plupart des députés visés
n'importe quoi que leurs assistants
parlementaires que parfois il ne
travaillait pas je cite personne je
laisse la justice faire son travail mais
en tout cas les électeurs doivent savoir
que ma remplaçante sera également mon
assistante parlementaire et enfin
j'aimerais également rappelé aux
électeurs que durant la dernière
mandature
les députés qui ont le plus travaillé
qui ont fait le plus de propositions de
loi qui ont fait le plus d'amendements
qui sont plus investis en commission ce
sont les écologistes on voit que le taux
d'absentéisme des écologistes à
l'assemblée est très faible
c'est également la raison pour laquelle
je sollicite la confiance des acteurs et
on termine ce premier tour de table avec
pascale poirot
dites nous pourquoi les électeurs
doivent t'ils vous faire confiance bien
parce que un député on doit le choisir
d'abord pour sa personnalité ses
compétences son engagement sa capacité à
travailler avec tous y compris ceux qui
pensent pas comme lui ou elle est pas
suivant son étiquette partisane surtout
des partis qui peut-être dans six mois
n'existeront plus sous la forme où ils
sont aujourd'hui
il faut que choisir aussi parce que je
n'abandonnerai jamais mes convictions
contre une future investiture je
garderai ma liberté de vote
je ne serai pas un mouton de panurge si
vous voulez lors des votes
ensuite je me battrai aussi pour lutter
contre le tout économique que les partis
principaux actuellement propulse en
avant la culture fait l'unité d'un pays
et elle ne s'achète pas tout comme la
personne humaine et puis enfin parce que
ça fait 27 ans que j'habite sur cette
circonscription que j'y vis que j'y
prends mes loisirs que j'y travaille
et que effectivement il faut être très
ancrée localement pour bien comprendre
comment tout cela se passe merci pour
vos réponses on poursuit avec une
première thématique l'emploi les
derniers chiffres du chômage sont tombés
il ya quelques jours le nombre de
chômeurs a reculé de 1% en avril c'est
évidemment encore insuffisant puisque 3
5 millions de personnes sont toujours
sans emploi en france jean noël barrot
on commence avec vous candidat investi
par la république en marche vous
proposez est d'appuyer un développement
économique fondé sur la complémentarité
des grandes entreprises et le tissu de
tpe pme
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
cette proposition oui vous avez raison
un jeune sur quatre au chômage c'est un
scandale il faut y mettre fin
ce que nous ferons c'est que nous nous
stimulerons les créations d'emplois en
libérant de les créations d'emploi
auprès des entreprises par la baisse des
charges qu'elle paye par le
rétablissement de l'exonération des
charges des heures supplémentaires et
par une flaque simo plus de flexibilité
et d'agilité dans leur capacité à
recruter en même temps nous re
valoriseront le travail en réduisant les
cotisations payées par les salariés et
la prime l activité et enfin pour celles
et ceux qui subissent le chômage
précisément nous étendons la couverture
du chômage aux indépendants aux artisans
et puis nous formerons un million de
jeunes et un million de demandeurs
d'emploi pour leur permettre de
retrouver l'emploi à yasmine benzema tu
si vous êtes élu fn quels types de loi
vous proposerez vous soutiendrez à
l'assemblée nationale pour relancer la
machine emploi ou en tout cas la
soutenir et je pense que le tissu
d'emploi se crée essentiellement par les
tpe pme qui sont actuellement confrontés
à deux difficultés d'une part recrutent
même plusieurs difficultés d'une part
recruter les bonnes compétences et
surtout du fait de problèmes de
trésorerie c'est pas leurs bons et leurs
carnets de commandes qui manquent mais
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas la trésorerie
suffisante pour pouvoir embaucher les
compétences dont ils ont besoin
d'autre part
difficultés des lois existantes
actuellement qui font que pour une tpe
pme qui pour les tpe pme qui n'ont pas
de service juridique il est presque
impossible de comprendre exactement
toutes les subtilités de la loi des lois
du code du travail et le simplifier
parce que vraiment on voit qu'au fur et
à mesure des années il s'est alourdi et
sans pour autant se clarifier donc
favorisé du pragmatisme de la
flexibilité pour les tpe pme est comme
ça crée de l'emploi en grâce marc
soriano on va on va poursuivre avec vous
vous reprenez le programme de la france
a soumise aux présidentielles l'un des
points mis en avant par jean luc
mélenchon et par vous aussi forcément
c'est mobiliser l'argent pour financer
les petites et moyennes entreprises et
la création d'emploi comment vous
comptez faire ça si vous êtes élue
députée sont tout à fait d'accord en
gros sur sept sont tout à fait sur
l'année sur la même ligne c'est à dire
les vieilles recettes sur la mamie la
république en marche je prends ma fille
à l'umih absolue ce sont les mêmes
vieilles recettes j'ai entendu parler de
flexibilité j'ai entendu parler de code
du travail trop lourd ne l'attendait
c'est exactement la même doxa libérale
la même les mêmes les mêmes les mêmes
refrains qu'on entend depuis déjà des
décennies et qui ne marche pas la baisse
des charges ça ne marche pas il ya plein
de solutions qui sont proposées sur la
flexibilité du marché de l'emploi depuis
combien de temps on essaye ça ce qui
fait le sel comme un temps et savait pas
que ça c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
prendre le travail non c'est pas comme
ça qu'il faut prendre à quelqu'un il
faut pour sortir il faut déjà instauré
une protection solidaire un
protectionnisme solidaire il faut il
faut investir sur des marchés créateurs
d'emplois c'est à dire la transition
énergétique l'agriculture paysanne
l'économie de la mer dans la fonction
publique exactement le contraire de ce
que
de ce qu'on nous propose là et je pense
pas du tout que ces solutions techniques
sur le marché du travail parce qu'on
sait très bien ce qui s'annonce qui
s'annonce c'est quoi c'est une réforme
de l'assurance chômage mais on va
expliquer aux chômeurs qu'au bout du
deuxième emploi il doit rentrer à la
maison
c'est si ça qu'on appelle la flexibilité
et c'est avec ça qu'on pense alors que
plus on a de protection - en othe
chômage évidemment vous êtes libre à
chaque fois de répondre de prendre la
parole
voudrais revenir sur quand je parlais de
flexibilité c'est pas la flex est pas
totalement la même flexibilité qu en
marche on n'est pas pour la loi de
travail déjà d'une part et contre la
future loi de travail qui s'annonce
oui la simplification du code de travail
ça veut pas forcément dire de supprimer
tout ce qui protège les les salariés
c'est surtout favoriser l'embauché et
favoriser le maintien dans l'emploi
on poursuit avec pascale poirot votre
vision vos propositions pour soutenir la
relance économique
ma vision c'est d'abord qui a deux
agriculteurs qui se suicident par
semaine des burn out à répétition dans
les entreprises donc soit on se dit on
continue dans le tout économique
bougeant quelques curseur mais on change
pas la révolution intellectuelle et à ce
moment-là ça avancera pas beaucoup ou
bien vraiment se dit il faut trouver les
leviers pour lâcher cette pression
durant demande des objectifs sur sur
l'économie et on développe les circuits
courts que les collectivités locales de
votre circonscription achètent tout ce
qu'elles peuvent acheter localement ce
serait quand même pas mal et au niveau
l'écologie aussi une agriculture
raisonnée comme disait marx rien de tout
à l'heure un grand plan pme pmi y
compris un volet gouvernance pour les
aider à progresser et à
s'internationaliser et puis travailler
beaucoup sur l'employabilité des gens
notamment dans les secteurs d'avenir et
pas seulement les salariés mais aussi
les indépendants trouver des leviers
parce que finalement le fait que
l'économie bouge ça on n'y peut pas
grand chose c'est le monde mais on peut
trouver les moyens de s'y préparer pour
que nos visions nous y adapter
et ça aujourd'hui ça fait vingt-cinq ou
trente ans que les différents partis qui
se succèdent ne trouve pas les leviers
suffisant pour changer la logique on va
poursuivre avec pascal thévenot puis
tente d'y lancer vous qui est le plus en
retard au niveau des temps de parole qui
vont s'afficher
massivement pendant l'émission pascal
thévenot candidat des républicains lui
dit vous soutenez un abaissement des
charges des entreprises
quand on est ce que ces chiffres et est
ce que c'est un abaissement massif que
vous souhaiter pour les entreprises mais
écoutez on souhaite un abaissement les
autres décharges de 10 milliards mais
surtout est ce qui nous différencie par
rapport aux autres c'est que je pars du
principe qu'on doit de faire confiance
aux gens aux tribus aux salariés qu'on
souhaite d'entreprise et c'est pas les
petites recettes qui vont dire oui je
vais privilégier les pme par rapport aux
grandes entreprises on a un écosystème
on a besoin de tout le monde et
simplement il faut que le chef
d'entreprise et confiance dans son
carnet de commandes dans ces embauches
et ça veut dire que moi si vous vous
souvenez il ya un an j'étais le seul
parmi les neuf candidats à soutenir la
version originale de la loi macron loi
sur le travail
après on sait ce qu'elle est devenue et
aujourd'hui en fait je suis déçu que
finalement emmanuel macron de repos se
pose pas la loi qu'il avait proposé
initialement il ya un an
et parce qu'elle allait comme dans le
bon sens et quand je vois qu'aujourd'hui
on propose de revenir sur les
entreprises et de la négociation sur une
entreprise mais avec un salarié validée
par un syndicat vous imaginez un artisan
une pme qui va accepter ça ne se fasse
ça ne se fera pas il faut donner
confiance
après vous imaginez on avait une recette
qui était au niveau des prud'hommes on
mettait un plafond pourquoi pas
maintenant aujourd'hui suite à ses
discussions qu'il a eues avec quelques
centrales syndicales il ya le plafond
est aussi le plancher ça veut dire que
vous êtes sûr de savoir ce que vous
allez perdre
et puis je pense qu'il faut un vrai
dialogue et pour avoir un vrai dialogue
il y avait une raison après guerre que
les syndicats historique soit
privilégiée au premier tour aujourd'hui
à plus de raison il faut faire confiance
aux salariés si on voit des salariés
s'intéressent à leur entreprise et qui
la défendent
qu'ils fassent tout pour qui la
croissance il faut que dès le premier
tour tout salarié puisse se présenter
le syndicat marc soriano vous dis je
vais justement jeu donnait la parole à
tous les syndicats le syndicat protéger
pour que ce soit des syndicats qui ne
dirigent pas l'entreprise par rapport au
niveau national mais avec des frais
critères permettant aussi je crois veut
la parole
on veut parler les urnes j'imagine pour
vous la relance de l'emploi ça passe par
une économie plus verte exactement alors
j'aimerais revenir sur la réforme du
code du travail parce qu'on nous dit
qu'on va simplifier le code du travail
or l'application des lois votées sous la
précédente mandature et notamment initié
par emmanuel macron a fait que les
saisine du conseil des prud'hommes ont
drastiquement diminué et en gros
aujourd'hui la réforme qu'on nous vend
c'est une réforme de la complexité
badinter avait proposé des principes qui
sont très intéressants on peut le
simplifier le code du travail et le
simplifier sa bénéficie aux salariés
aujourd'hui au mouvement de la
complexité supplémentaire parce que la
complexité c'est favorable aux grosses
boîtes si je schématise voilà maintenant
j'aimerais parler de quelque chose qui
m'est cher c'est la régulation de la
finance et notamment le mécanisme de ce
qu'on appelle le lb ou alors le lb au
c'est quoi c'est quand une entreprise un
fonds rachète une autre entreprise par
l'endettement en gros elle finance les
parts sociales ou les actions par
l'endettement
quelle est la conséquence c'est que
cette ce fonds pour pouvoir rembourser
le crédit est obligé de faire dégager
d'énormes marges aux entreprises en
question est en général toutes les
stratégies industrielles à long terme
finissent par dépérir
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
que la société se retrouve en
redressement judiciaire ou en
liquidation judiciaire
et moi je propose quelque chose de tout
simple si je suis élu député
je proposerai un droit de préemption aux
salariés qui se mettent en scope pouvoir
acquérir la société en question voilà et
enfin j'aimerais revenir sur
l'agriculture biologique qui aujourd'hui
un formidable levier d'emploi qui à la
fois bon pour la santé publique
je pense qu'il faut tout simplement
défiscaliser toute l'agriculture
biologique parce que à long terme c'est
à la fois des emplois et du bien-être
pour nos concitoyens
pascale poirot vous souhaitiez réagir
deux choses
et d'abord il ya deux sujets dont on n'a
pas parlé il ya un chômage qui est très
lourd et un chômage de longue durée qui
est très haut il ya des initiatives très
intéressante par des associations de
création d'entreprises à but d'emplois
c'est à dire je prends de force avait
pas de forces en tout cas avec une
certaine volonté des chômeurs de longue
durée et je leur donne un poids dans des
secteurs non marchands ou en tout cas où
la streak le règle marchande ne suffit
pas notamment beaucoup de services
d'aidé à la personne
et donc ces initiatives il faut les
possibles pour vraiment attaquer le
chômage à la racine et deuxièmement on
ne parle pas de l'économique
collaborative et des nouvelles
technologies je veux dire aujourd'hui
airbnb avec 6000 salariés et accord avec
190 mille salariés vendent le même
nombre de nuitées c'est quand même une
révolution sur lequel les grands partis
sont nés pascal couraud gendre jean noël
jeanneney le barreau vous êtes plus ou
moins à attaquer par certains candidats
en bien ou en mal ou ça va passer le
mois où ça va trop loin sur la réforme
du code du travail
est-ce que qu'est ce que vous dites que
pour la défendre puisque j'imagine que
vous là où la soutenir
non mais pour rebondir sur ce que disait
pascal thévenot effectivement à 6000 ça
n'allait pas assez loin
ou en tout cas que le projet qu'il avait
peut-être soutenu le projet au moment où
il avait été élaboré je crois que c'est
ce qui est un petit peu lancé le
mouvement d' emmanuel macron c'est de
dire que en privé un certain nombre de
députés
tout autour de l'hémicycle données en
aval à ces propositions mais que dès
lors que il se retrouvait dans
l'hémicycle qui reprenait une posture
politicienne qui les empêchait de
pouvoir voter pour des propositions qui
leur paraissait pourtant de bon sens
tanguy relance oui thierry âge appuie
pascal thévenot ensuite moi j'aimerais
juste qu'on m'explique comment avec des
accords d'entreprise vous allez pouvoir
déroger à la durée légale du temps de
travail sachant qu'un accord c'est comme
un contrat et que la loi est supérieur
hiérarchique non il faudra que vous
expliquiez comment vous allez faire pour
garder la durée légale du temps de
travail à 35 heures telles qu elle est
gravée dans la loi est donnée
supériorité aux accords d'entreprise
jean noël barrot vous pouvez vous pouvez
répondre puisque vous êtes en retard sur
le temps de parole puis ce sera au tour
de pascal thévenot vous êtes un peu en
retard au niveau du ton parole peut-être
répondra à tanguy et brûlant l'idée de
l' inversion de la hiérarchie des normes
c'est simplement de remettre de
l'agilité dans la capacité des
entreprises à recruter et tout en
faisant attention à ce que les salariés
et des droits renforcés et une preuve
des protections renforcées ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'ils pourront
bénéficier du chômage s'il démissionne
et ça veut dire qu'ils pourront avoir
accès à une formation renforcée tout au
long de l'année
évaluer les conséquences de cet
assouplissement 7,7 les conséquences de
cet assouplissement il faudra les
évaluer et ça fait partie du programme
parce qu'ils sont très claires vous
savez entre deux entreprises qui sont
brute vous avez quelqu'un qui passe aux
39 heures quand le concurrent passe à 30
noeuds york l'hôtel encore à 35 est ce
que va dire le patron à son banc qu'il
valide qui sera au courant que l'hôte
étonnant donc si vous voulez avoir des
facilités de trésorerie monsieur jeu va
falloir vous mettiez vous employez au
39e vous voyez bien coq quand on connaît
on ce même projet les protections
protègera les salariés et les salariés
d'une entreprise avec un entrepôt avec
un entrepreneur ou un patron qui jouent
pas le jeu ou qui est pas de bonne foi
ils auront dans le cas d'espèce que vous
citez ce pas le cas dans tous les
secteurs mais ils auront la possibilité
d'aller chez le concurrent synesis ont
maltraité pascal thévenot
est ce que oui deux réponses déjà par
rapport à ça vous avez raison et votre
question mais il a des difficultés et
l'incohérence des manuels matheron c'est
qu'il veut donner la liberté de
négociation au sein d'entreprises sur le
temps de travail mais ne revient pas sur
les 35 heures donc ce qui veut dire que
de toute façon il n'y a pas de
négociation de cinq heures de travail
c'est toute l'incohérence qui entre nous
deux et après quand je parlais de d'une
campagne où j'avais soutenu la loi
initiale des menus de mac moi qui ne
reprend pas aujourd'hui pour moitié et
bien détrompez vous si vous aviez suivi
les débats c'est ma première question
d'actualité c'était pour soutenir
justement cette loi et j'avais été
soutenue et du coup et c'est peut-être
la connaissance du terrain la relève et
d'autre mais en général à tous ceux qui
avaient voté contre ils ont continué
mais aujourd'hui je pense que si on peut
avoir un pays qui avance et pas perdre
50 plus ils font qu'on puisse arriver
peut-être une grande coalition avec des
gens qui s'investissent sur un projet et
pas simplement sur du marketing sur un
homme et à partir du moment où on
s'engage sur un projet chacun assumera à
partir mais il est authentique avec ce
qui pose alors la position pour terminer
sur cette thématique du front national
puis on regardera les chronomètres
précisément de chacun alors d'abord je
voulais revenir sur l' annonce de
formation c'est bien la formation mais
il faut qu'elle soit adaptée aux
débouchés qu'il ya dans le marché du
travail parce qu'on s'aperçoit même en
tant que conseiller régional que
beaucoup de formations professionnelles
proposées ne débouche sur rien donc
c'est bien d'avoir de l'information mais
il faut être encore une fois pragmatique
et être à l'écouté de
des patrons des employeurs justement et
des débouchés sur le marché après pour
ce qui est des négociations nous on
serait favorable puisque les syndicats
ont perdu un peu leur représentativité
il à terre plus tellement c'est de
remettre des négociations par branches
d'activités qui sont complémentaires et
du coup qui reprennent tous les emplois
d'une même d'un même secteur d'activité
et qui permettrait beaucoup plus de
complémentarité
voilà oui allez-y en plus vous avez un
peu de retard et en paroles mais en
profiter quand même monsieur macron
certes dit qu'ils ne touchent pas aux 35
heures mais c'est une posture faut pas
se tromper il dit ça pour mes propos
pour pas éveillé pour pas pour percevoir
des flèches mais il va tout faire sur le
terrain pour que les 35 heures soient
complètement vidés de leur substance
c'est ça qui va se passer
il faut arrêter de tromper les gens
celle ci s'est su être une réponse de
jean noël barrot il tanguait welland
dans la réalité négociée d'un niveau si
on vous activerez segnora peu trop
sacrifier les trentenaires à coeur de
façon un peu caché si je comprends bien
non mais c'est évident enfin je veux
dire s'il ya un affichage politique on
ne touche pas aux 35 heures mais rue par
rue
le temps de travail va changer c'est ça
qui va se passer le projet était que là
il a reçu un mandat de la majorité des
français même si un certain nombre de
français sont pas exprimés en faveur de
deux ni l'un ni l'autre des candidats à
l'élection au deuxième tour la nacelle
ce ce pro ce programme-là sera soutenu
par la majorité présidentielle
si la majorité présidentielle moi
j'aimerais répondre sur cette histoire
de 35 heures parce que je trouve qu'on
se moque un peu du monde
personne n'empêche une entreprise de
faire en sorte que ces salariés
travaillent plus de 35 heures la
question qui se pose c'est qu'à partir
du moment où travaillent plus de 35
heures les heures supplémentaires sont
majorés alors quand on dit qu'on défende
pouvoir d'achat il ya un paradoxe veut
dire que voilà je crois que la limite
c'est la limite imposée par le droit
européen et ses 48 heures voilà sauf que
effectivement à partir de la 36e heure
les heures supplémentaires sont majorées
qui à mon sens va donc dans le sens du
pouvoir d'achat que vous défendez
ardemment oui et nous allons rétablir
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
très efficace pour les finances
publiques vous il y aura d'autres
il ya des manières plus d'intelligence
mais benzema rapport au temps des
manières les plus intelligents de la
trainière les dépenses publiques on va
d'abord regarder vos votes on parle pour
voir où est ce que vous en êtes
précisément ça va s'afficher dans
quelques instants je crois qu'il y avait
quand même pas mal d'écart entre les
candidats vous voyez jean-noël barrot un
petit peu retard marc soriano aussi
yasmine benzema tu aussi du coup parole
à vous au front national vous souhaitiez
d'ailleurs réagir juste dire que nous
nous sommes pour le maintien des 35
heures après effectivement la
possibilité d'avoir des heures
supplémentaires payées bien sûr et
défiscalisées parce que c'est vrai que
c'était une bonne mesure pour tous ceux
qui font des heures supplémentaires et
qui n'ont pas forcément le choix
marc soriano souhaitez vous ajouter
quelque chose puisque vous êtes en
retard aussi sur le temps de parole sur
sur la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires par exemple quelle est
votre position à la subdivision 12
heures supplémentaires c'est une très
bonne chose qu'on est pour les gens qui
ont des moyens réduits c'est toujours
c'est toujours ça de gagné c'est une
mesure
j'ai trouvé moi personnellement tout à
fait honnête mais enfin évidemment
insuffisante
moi ce que je ce que je remarque je le
redis c'est que les recettes qui nous
sont proposés sont tous vont toujours
chercher dans les vieux dans les
vieilles dans les vieilles marmites sont
toujours des histoires où on joue
finalement plus ou moins à la marge mais
on ne s'occupe pas du coeur du problème
qui est le travail des gens parlent
d'emplois n'en parle pas de travail
travail ou vrai travail quand est ce que
on ouvre des secteurs qui donne du
travail pas des gens qui dans les
rues de paris t'ont livrer des sandwichs
en auto entreprise parce que c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer l'ubs et
risation de la société c'est un vrai
scandale
moi personnellement je trouve ou en tout
cas il faut la maîtriser
il faut que les plateformes il faut que
les plateformes sont contrôlés on
autorise à ces sociétés de faire
n'importe quoi vous disiez tout à
l'heure au complot c'est vous qui
parlait des bénéfices de ces sociétés de
ces plateformes mais enfin il faut
savoir combien qu'elles ne payent pas
leurs impôts en france que certes je le
sais ceux qui en bénéficient sont bien
contents d'avoir un revenu grâce mais à
grâce à ce genre de service mais enfin
ça une limite au bout d'un moment le
marché d'engorger les caisses qui se
passe les gens travaillent 70 heures par
semaine sans aucune protection sociale
et il est là le problème c'est que c'est
plus baer n'est pas la solution
maintenant on avance largement de
l'exercice se désole aussi parce que je
ne dis pas du tout qu'il faut pousser ce
genre de solution simplement je lire
l'économie numérique et collaborative
donne des enjeux pour le futur en termes
de protection sociale justement il faut
absolument la maîtrise et c'était ça mon
propos et moi et en tant que chef
d'entreprise là parce que moi je suis à
la fois chef d'entreprise à la fois je
connais très bien les collectivités
locales puisque ça a été mais clients
depuis 30 ans sur les 35 heures pour
faire attention parce que si on les
faisait sauter d'un seul coup
ballet couvre montré de 10 % parce que
je veux dire les salariés se ferait pas
payées 39 heures payées 35
voilà donc il faut être alors on va
passer désormais non mais qu obama
quand quand on est le tenant de
l'efficacité budgétaire des économies
budgétaires il faut savoir que la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires ça coûtait une fortune
et on l'a bien vu sous la mandature de
nicolas sarkozy puisque 25% de la dette
française aujourd'hui a été créé pendant
les cinq ans de nicolas sarkozy
compenser cet effort par le fait
d'inciter les entreprises à payer leurs
impôts en france qui permettra une
refiscalisation et c'est pour ça que je
dis que les entreprises c'est surtout
les tpe pme qui créent de l'emploi en
france comparé aux grandes entreprises
qui souvent délocalisent parce qu'un
coup de travail plus plus bas à
l'étranger vous retrouvez cette
incitation pour maintenir et pour faire
payer les grands groupes en france
également commenté pascal clavier mais
là je pense que quand on mélange un peu
près tous les problèmes ouais parce que
je pense que cette thématique emploi
cette année sera la priorité des
priorités c'est lorsqu'une et côté
salariés plus chez une entreprise qui va
faire remettre un peu le débat dans
l'ordre mais justement enfin si vous
voulez que le coût du travail baisse
c'est bien il faut sûrement baisser les
charges et faire une sorte qu'il ya que
le salarié puisse retrouver du pouvoir
d'achat ça veut dire que si la solution
d'augmenter stg
c'est peut-être pas au gré de détendre
la bonne chose mais le parce que le
matraquage fiscal on en parlera
peut-être il faut arrêter et c'est ça
qu'il faut faire confiance parce que
quand une négociation dans mon
entreprise se fait j'ai pas la majorité
des salariés qui va concilier qui va
accepter une mesure qui n'ira pas dans
le sens de l'entreprise dans la leur
donc avant tout quand vous négociez dans
une entreprise et encore plus dans les
tpe ou des pme
les salariés ont qu'une envie c'est de
voir leur entreprise croître est en
croissance et à voir leur salaire en
croissance y a personne qui va accepter
trop y croire
huit heures avant les temps de parole
est bien d'accord qui vont s'afficher
bientôt puis on va devoir passer à votre
carte blanche tout de suite qu'on attend
un peu les temps de parole qui vont
s'afficher en tout cas la carte blanche
vous permet à chacun d'entre vous on
voit les temps de parole justement qui
sait
vous êtes à peu près tous à égalité
jean-noël barrot un peu de retard marc
soriano un peu d'avancé ça va du coup un
peu calibré et votre carte blanche à à
chacun on va commencer avec deux j'en
aurai le barreau pour la république en
marche
la thématique que vous souhaitez mettre
en avant et du coup vous avez un peu de
temps pour pour la développer un peu
plus de temps oui alors d'abord ce que
ce que ce à quoi nous croyons c'est à la
restauration de l'autorité de l'état
quand il ya des lois qui sont écrites il
ya là nombreuses elles doivent être
appliquées et ça s'applique en matière
de fiscalité
on l'a dit sur la sur la fiscalité des
entreprises pour certaines qui font de
l'optimisation qui doivent être attrapé
ça s'applique aussi en matière de
sécurité dans nos villes et nos
quartiers quand des actes d'incivilité
sont réalisés il faut qu'il puisse être
sanctionné rapidement et quand les
peines sont prononcés elle doit être
exécuté l'application stricte de la loi
quand elle est écrite permettra de
redonner confiance à nos concitoyens
dans dans nos lois et dans nos
institutions et de faire avancer ces
lois et d'en proposer d'autres en ayant
la confiance des citoyens
pascal e vous souhaitiez le continuer
excusez moi non je vous ai coupé j'ai
cru que c'était la fin de votre
intervention en libye vous pouvez y
aller je vous en prie maintenant les i
c'est non mais je regarde danser bon
parce que pascale poirot excusez moi
pour votre carte blanche
si vous avez un point à mettre en avant
moi j'ai un point à mettre en avant ses
deux suivants
on peut imaginer les réformes
économiques les plus ambitieuses les
formes politiques institutionnels les
plus ambitieuses le prérequis c'est que
les français soient unis ils sont
actuellement extrêmement fragmenté et la
priorité de la priorité du débat
présidentiel aurait dû être
qu'est ce qui fait que les français vont
de nouveau faire communauté nation
ensemble et donc pour ça moi je
préconise deux choses d'abord il faut
réformer profondément l'école il faut
restaurer l'autorité à l'école les
savoirs fondamentaux lire écrire compter
et surtout imaginer un récit national
dans lequel les français et françaises
de différentes origines se retrouve dans
un imaginaire commun pour faire union et
deuxièmement mois je souhaiterais qu'on
réinvente le service national
obligatoire pour tous
réinventer ça veut pas dire faire
exactement ce qu'il était il attend pas
du tout il faut que ce soit pour les
jeunes hommes et jeunes femmes et que ce
soit un service national civil
c'est-à-dire que chaque française
français donne 8 à 10 mois de sa vie
donnée pour une cause humanitaire pour
un service utile à la nation et qu'il
partage avec des français d'autres
origines d'autre origine géographique
d'autres origines sociales désolé de
vous couper pour le temps de parole on
va passer à pascal thévenot le député
sortant votre carte blanche et puis on
enchaînera avec les conclusions tout le
monde ne pourra pas parler sur forcément
sur la sur la conclusion le même temps
la russie pascal thévenot là par rapport
aux sujets qu'on a abordé je pense qu'il
ya un sujet qui piqua pas été abordée et
qui est complètement oubliée du
président actuel c'est la famille et la
famille ça veut dire bien sûr être en
sécurité mais savent aussi aux aussi
dire pouvoir éduquer ses enfants pouvoir
là à voir une formation mais aussi
pouvoir retrouver du pouvoir d'achat et
pour pouvoir retrouver du bureau d'achat
ça veut dire qu'il faut arrêter de tout
faire sur l'impôt il faut avoir comme
vision de la croissance et c'est pour ça
que quand on regarde je reviens dessus à
l'augmentation de la csg
ça veut dire que vous allez voir les
petites retraites qui vont être matraque
et ça veut dire que les petites
économies vont être matraque et ça veut
dire que les fonctionnaires qui
commencent à se rendre compte des biens
vont avoir la cg qui va augmenter parce
que vous ça vous a pas échappé qu'elle
ne paye pas de charges pour le chômage
et puis il faut aussi la sécurisation c
est notamment dans les circonscriptions
la plupart des familles veille avoir
accès à la propriété et ça veut dire que
il faut arrêter aussi de matraquer le
propriétaire quand j'entends emmanuel
macron parler de rente patrimoniale moi
c'est quelque chose que je comprends pas
et qui choque beaucoup de mes
concitoyens et pour aussi faire
confiance aux aux municipalités et aux
mères et quand on veut supprimer la taxe
d'habitation ça veut dire que les maires
vont faire quoi qui vont augmenter la
taxe foncière ou ils vont supprimer les
services publics ont des taxes foncières
c'est encore les propriétaires ont
poursuivi avec carte blanche à katyn
yasmine benzema excusez moi oui mais moi
en fait je suis là pour défendre la
france et les français
mais sur quoi sur quatre piliers
principaux pour moi c'est la famille
l'enseignement d'identité et la sécurité
voilà donc la famille parce que c'est le
socle fondateur de
de notre vie c'est là qu'on commence
notre vie et c'est là qu'on allait
l'éducation justement comme enfin c'est
comme ça qu'on se construit et donc
inciter les familles à se développer
correctement sereinement dans un cadre
de vie correct et sans avoir la
sensation que on ne peut pas enfin on
peut pas fonder de famille puisque on
n'a pas les revenus nécessaires ou qu'on
est trop matraquer fiscalement justement
voilà donc retrouver un la famille comme
socle principal ensuite l'enseignement
puisque c'est ce qui permet à tous
d'avoir le socle commun des dés de
savoir lire compter et connaître son
histoire parce que quel que soit notre
origine
c'est l'école de la république qui
permet de connaître l'histoire du pays
dans lequel on vit et qui nous donne cet
amour de ce pays et donc ça ça enchaîne
sur l'identité puisque voilà c'est
savoir d'où on vient et pour être muni
et pouvoir vivre en paix avec les autres
et la sécurité publique la sécurité
oui tanguy roulant pour les verts pour
le parti communiste pour le ps votre
carte blanche ça sur l'éducation parce
que c'est un lieu que je connais bien
puisque pendant toutes mes études j'ai
travaillé dans différents établissements
scolaires et donc aujourd'hui on voit
que la france baisse dans le fameux
classement pisa et on se dit qu'est ce
qui se passe nos enfants sont pas bien
il après le malheur ils apprennent mal
leurs leçons et c est tout le monde et
est affolée sauf que quand on regarde ce
qui marche c'est ce qui marche en
finlande et qu'est ce qui marche en
finlande c'est les solutions que les
écologistes préconisent depuis des
années c'est introduire de l'éducation
dans l'école ça veut dire que on
accueille les enfants pendant plus
longtemps on ne laisse plus d'autonomie
ils peuvent faire des activités extra
scolaires au sein de l'école résultat
les courses quand on fait ça comme par
hasard on caracole en tête du classement
pisa
donc moi j'en ai un peu marre d'entendre
tout et son contraire sur l'éducation
souvent on estime que les enfants c'est
de la faute des enfants les pauses enfin
aujourd'hui sont soumis à la précarité
au délitement de la famille ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent et l'école ne joue pas
son rôle parce qu'elle n'a pas les
moyens de jouer son rôle pour la france
insoumise moi je veux d'abord dire je
vais pas possible au début que
je connais très bien la circonscription
que je laboure et dans tous les sens en
tant que metteur en scène avec une
compagnie théâtrale
donc j'ai une vision un peu nomade de
cette circonscription
je la connais bien et moi je voulais
quand même revenir un peu au contexte
parce qu'avant de pouvoir développer nos
idées il faut que les français ne fasse
confiance et aujourd'hui s'ils ne font
pas confiance à la france un sou nous il
va y avoir un troisième tour où
quatrième touché tout le monde on et
sociale très violent donc j'insiste là
dessus parce que on est à un moment
politique très particulier et que si une
majorité que nous sommes de gauche la
gauche politique ne portent pas cette
fois sa voix dans le pays ça se passera
ailleurs et je peux vous garantir avec
les réformes qui arrive ça va être très
dur c'est une première chose et je
terminerai juste pas ce qui nous importe
beaucoup qui est la règle verte
nous sommes des humains avant tout nous
sommes des humains en connection avec la
nature et et ne pas oublier ça l'humain
plutôt que les chiffres il y en a marre
des chiffres et des dogmes et des cours
alors des chiffres quand même on a
dépassé les 35 minutes d'émission donc
on a des salles déjà dépassé le temps
qui était prévu pour le débat on va
peut-être voir une dernière fois les
temps de parole pour éventuellement et
rééquilibrer si besoin le temps de
parole alors j'imagine que jean-noël
barrot vous n'êtes pas à jour puisque
vous avez parlé deux minutes de moins
que certains candidats
vous aurez quand même le droit de
conclure du coup très rapidement sur sur
sur ce débat si vous souhaitez mettre un
dernier point en avance puisque on me
confirme vous avez un peu de un peu de
retard quand même écouter si je si je
suis élu j'aurai à coeur de soutenir des
politiques qui préserveront les
équilibres qui font la qualité de notre
cadre de vie
je soutiendrai politique qui appuieront
le développement économique
articulé entre les grands groupes comme
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure les pme
les artisans et commerçants de nos de
nos centres bourgs et de nos villes je
souhaiterais politique qui investiront
dans l'éducation et la culture pour que
nos enfants aient les meilleures
conditions d'enseignement et pour
promouvoir la méritocratie je
soutiendrai la transition écologique
proposé par emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement et sa majorité je l'espère
et puis aussi je soutiens dans les
politiques qui favorisent la mobilité
les transports qui sont un sujet est
crucial pour notre circonscription et
les transports en commun en particulier
et les points noirs routiers qui
conviendra de pouvoir résorber et enfin
je soutiendrai politique qui nous
permettront de maintenir l'offre de
soins l'offre de services et puis le
déploiement du très haut débit et la 4g
pour réduire la fracture numérique entre
les territoires et à nouveau préserver
la qualité de notre cadre de vie
merci à vous si ce d'être venu ce soir
en plateau évidemment aussi les temps de
parole ne sont pas parfaitement
équilibré nous essaierons jusqu'à
jusqu'au premier tour de l'airé
équilibré dans le reste de nos émissions
et journaux merci à vous si ce d'être
venu en plateau on poursuit ce débat
pour la deuxième circonscription des
yvelines
dans quelques minutes avec cinq nouveaux
candidats mais tout de suite un sujet
pour vous présenter les enjeux sur le
territoire avec mélanie poquet de retour
dans les bureaux de vote
un an plus tard la deuxième
circonscription des yvelines a connu en
mars 2016 une législative partielle
suite à la démission de valérie pécresse
élue à la présidence de la région ile de
france le 20 mars 2016 c'est pascal
thévenot qui est élu député avec 72% des
voix mais avec seulement 26 % de
participation
l'élu les républicains remet son mandat
en jeu avec l'étiquette de favori
la circonscription est
traditionnellement ancrée à droite 17
candidats se sont déclarés pour le
premier tour du 11 juin prochain
le principal adversaire du candidat les
républicains pourrait être jean noël
barrot
l'enseignant chercheur de 34 ans est
actuellement conseiller départemental de
haute loire à la rentrée prochaine et
rejoindra le campus hec de jouy-en-josas
le candidat est investi pour cette
législative par la république en marche
partie des manuels macron mais celui qui
pourrait ravir des voix pascal thévenot
c'est pascale poirot le candidat
à divers droite est soutenu par le parti
chrétien démocrate
il se présente pour la première fois
lors de la partielle de 2016 benjamin
lac ont soutenu lui aussi par le pcd
avait obtenu 9 56% des suffrages
autre prétendant le front national
représenté par yasmine belmadi actuelle
conseillère régionale d'île de france
le parti espère réitérer le score de
2016 où il était arrivé 4e et avait
obtenu 9 38% des voix
à noter que dans cette circonscription
le parti socialiste a trouvé un accord
avec europe ecologie les verts et le
parti radical de gauche pour ne
présenter qu'un seul candidat
et c'est l'avocat tanguy ruellan qui a
été choisi le nouveau parti créé lors de
la présidentielle france insoumise a
aussi son candidat l'écrivain metteur en
scène et acteur marc soriano est un
fidèle de la première heure de jean luc
mélenchon ex candidats sont aussi dans
la course à axel brunet candidat divers
gauche christophe pitié pour le parti
animalistes jérémy biz est déjà candidat
en 2016 pour france écologie pascal
casimir perier gipon tu le vois
françoise florelle céline julier
emmanuel 2,20 hélène janis et jean-guy
sayus et sylvain gargasson le 11 juin
prochain plus de 85 mille inscrits sont
appelés à glisser leur bulletin dans
l'urne au poursuit ce débat avec cinq
nouveaux invités qui viennent tout juste
de s'installer on le rappelle séduit
diact vous êtes sûrement essoufflé on
poursuit ce débat avec jérémy bizet et
candidats écologistes soutenus par
france écologie notamment pascal casimir
périer et ipte et candidats divers et
les neiges a glissé candidate d'extrême
gauche investi par lutte ouvrière
sylvain gargasson étiqueté aussi
candidat divers membres de l'union
populaire républicaine et françoise
florelle candidate de deux bouts
la france bonsoir à tous petit c'est
foraine forêt les excuser moi vous êtes
pardonner on va on va rendre un petit
donné là on va vous donner la parole
j'ai donné là les ce qui était indiqué
par là par la préfecture vous connaissez
la règle du jeu puisque vous avez
sûrement regardé le premier débat libre
à vous de vous répondre répondre à vos
opposants politiques
les temps de paroles seront en revanche
chronométrés et on débute avec une
première question simple qui permet de
faire un premier tour de table la même
question pour tous les candidats
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
voté pour vous on commence avec vous
jérémy bizet vous vous présentez pour la
deuxième fois sur cette circonscription
vous étiez déjà candidat lors de
l'élection partielle l'an passé alors
pourquoi doivent-ils vous faire
confiance
pourquoi parce que je pense que la
circonscription et l'état a besoin d'un
député de proximité d'un hôpital réputé
qui connaît son territoire j'y suis né
je n'ai achevé rose en 1989 je lis à
cerner la ville depuis 1992
je suis un député indépendant je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens ont besoin
de candidats qui dépasse le clivage
droite gauche traditionnelle donc je
souhaite pouvoir porter une voix
écologiste indépendante qui prend en
considération les besoins des citoyens
qui vivent sur le territoire un candidat
indépendant aussi du clivage indépendant
qui connaît son territoire comme je les
dis qui connaît les problèmes ruraux
aujourd'hui souvent les élus sont
essentiellement des zones urbaines et
puis il ya un écologiste réaliste qui
prend en considération les
problématiques quotidiennes des gens et
pas juste les problèmes idéologiques au
poursuivait avec vous pascal casimir
périer à vous aussi c'est votre deuxième
tentative sur cette circonscription vous
étiez une troisième même vous étiez
alors moi j'ai noté que vous étiez déjà
candidat en 2007 vous l'étiez aussi
auparavant 2002 en 2002 donc votre
troisième tentative sur la
circonscription
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance à leur déjà
première remarque
vous m'avez dit que j'étais un d'hiver
en fait je suis en adhérant au marché je
suis un candidat en marche mais je n'ai
pas l'investiture officielle
donc je vous fais un scoop oui j'ai
d'épinards et juste je vous précise que
les temps de parole est chronométré donc
vous m'aimez fait d'accord c'est votre
choix
donc j'ai fait un scoop j'ai mis le
préfet des yvelines au tribunal
administratif en référé pour parce que
je lui ai fait une semaine que je lui
demande de modifier ma science politique
en marche
donc maintenant c'est le juge qui va
prendre la décision donc dans 48 heures
on aura la décision est normalement j'ai
vraiment ma nuances politiques en marche
alors pourquoi je me présente tout
simplement parce que je considère que le
candidat investi pas en marche en fait
c'est un candidat modem il arrive sur la
circonscription mais il a juste été
étudiant à hec
donc ce qui se passe finalement c'est
que on n'a pas de vrais candidats en
marche donc moi je suis 100% marche 100%
local j'habite à magny les hameaux
depuis plus de 43 ans et donc je vais
défendre la politique d' emmanuel macron
est par contre ce serait un député
incorruptible et donc qu'est-ce que
c'est un député un correctif c'est un
député qui ne dit pas amen à tout les
lobbys qui existe et puis mon grand dada
je veux reprendre le flambeau de rené
dosière rené dosière il à celui qu'a
demandé le budget de l'elysée et qu'il a
obtenus et qu'il a fait modifier voilà
donc ma candidature et après j'ai
proposé quelques idées pour la
candidature et une par exemple la
reconnaissance du vote blanc
voilà donc ça je m'engage à obtenir de
reconnaissance du vote blanc lors de la
prochaine mandature
hélène jaillissait pour pour lutte
ouvrière pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils vous faire confiance je me
présente pour permettre aux électeurs
qui ont voté pour nathalie arthaud
l'élection présidentielle de pouvoir
faire ce geste
et à ceux qui ont apprécié les idées et
le programme qu'elle a défendus mais qui
ont au cd au vote utile de pouvoir voter
pour ses idées pour voter pour le compte
des travailleurs alors bien sûr c'est
pas les élections qui vont changer le
sort des travailleurs ça se saurait si
non mais parce qu'en fait ça se résume à
choisir celui ou ceux qui vont gérer les
affaires de la bourgeoisie mais les
élections ça permet quand même aux
travailleurs de faire entendre leur voix
et en votant pour lutte ouvrière pour ma
candidature
ça leur permet de dire que c'est sur le
terrain des luttes qui pourra inverser
le cours des choses
donc le vote pour mâcon
ida tueur c'est un vote pour le camp des
travailleurs c'est un vote de conscience
sylvain gargasson poursuit ce premier
tour de table pour lui plaire même
question sur cette confiance des
électeurs eh bien écoutez si je me
présente aujourd'hui devant les
électeurs c'est principalement pour
représenter l'upm lui perd aujourd'hui
n'a pas de député à l'assemblée
nationale et nous portons des des
questions très intéressantes notamment
sur l'union européenne notre
appartenance à l'euro et notre
appartenance à l'otan
nous avons aussi beaucoup de questions
sur des questions démocratiques
économiques et et nous voudrions pouvoir
un peu apporter notre voix et notre
notre expertise même dans certains de
ces sujets qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
ne sont pas reconnus cette candidature
elle est aussi importante pour lui père
notamment au niveau des moyens
financiers et aussi des moyens
médiatiques on aura pu remarquer que les
français viennent de découvrir françois
asselineau à la télé ça fait quand même
10 ans que lui perd exister disant que
lui père est inexistant dans les médias
et d'ailleurs on peut voir que la chape
de plomb et et retomber aussitôt
l'élection terminée nous aussi nous
avons un problème avec le ministère de
l'intérieur sur le sur le nuancier c'est
que lui père n'y apparaît pas en tant
que parti alors que nous sommes le parti
de france qui propose ont le plus de
candidats donc voilà il est important
que les gens votent pour nous l'upm pour
moi mais pour les autres
circonscriptions aussi pour nous aider à
porter nos idées et a lancé un débat
national françoise terminer ce tour de
table pour debout la france pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance et bien
les lecteurs peuvent et d'abord pourquoi
j'ai rejoint debout la france parce que
je j'adhère complètement aux idées de
nicolas dupont aignan c'est quelqu'un
qui est intègre qui est humain et
lorsque l'on parle d'intégrité ça c'est
quelque chose que j'aimerais que tous
les députés puissent présenter c'est à
dire un casier judiciaire vierge
voilà c'était quelque chose auquel je
tiens énormément et montrer aux gens que
un député peut être député tout en étant
intègres et honnêtes on passe merci pour
vos réponses et ce premier tour de table
on passe maintenant à notre première
thématique l'emploi on connaît la
situation française avec un léger mieux
du chômage depuis quelques mois mais un
taux toujours plus élevés que les autres
puissances économiques
emmanuel macron a fait de la réforme du
code du travail une priorité de son
quinquennat hélène janis et vous est
diamétralement opposée à une telle
réforme
vous souhaitez notamment pour lutte
ouvrière interdire les licenciements et
imposer un salaire minimum de 1800 euros
net par mois
est ce que c'est possible je commencerai
par dire qu'effectivement le chômage
c'est un fléau
pas une seule famille ouvrière n'était
pas renié et
c'est quand même 6 millions de chômeurs
aujourd'hui donc quand on nous dit que
les chiffres du chômage en diminue c'est
quand même 6 millions de chômeurs
ce sont des familles qui sont jetés dans
la misère qui sont marginalisés il était
aussi développement de l'individualisme
parce que ça met les travailleurs en
concurrence les uns avec les autres
mais le fléau enfin le chômage ce n'est
pas une fatalité c'est une politique qui
est menée par l'ensemble du patronat et
ils se servent commencé ils se servent
du chômage comme une à une arme contre
l'ensemble des travailleurs parce que on
nous explique pour lutter contre le
chômage il faut que les entreprises
retrouvent la compétitivité mais ce
qu'ils appellent la compétitivité c'est
une guerre sociale qui est menée par
l'anc par l'ensemble du patronat contre
les travailleurs et se sert justement du
chômage des hommes pour imposer à ceux
qui ont gardé leur emploi
ma de travailler encore plus de buzz dé
baisser les salaires d'imposer la
précarité généralisée de faire sauter
les protections sociales
donc c'est le chômage c'est un fléau
c'est une arme qui utilisent les patrons
et quand on nous dit justement que la
compétitivité c'est ce qui permettrait
de faire baisser le chômage
on se rend compte que la produit la
compétitivité en fait mais ce sont les
profits ce sont des profits records mais
le chômage lui alors dans le côté il ya
les grandes fortunes les riches
deviennent plus riches les actionnaires
hamas remplissent leurs coffres forts
mais de l'autre de l'autre côté ces
fortunes sont faites sur le dos des
travailleurs
alors justement comme vous le disiez
nous on met en avant des revendications
pour le comment sauver justement la peau
des travailleurs ils casseront nets par
mois et interdire les licenciements
vous avez le temps de paroles qui
défilent du coup ça va savourer voilà la
première des mesures en tout cas c'est
d'interdire les licenciements et de
répartir le travail entre tous et la
deuxième quand on travaille c'est pour
avoir un salaire etc pour vivre
dignement de ce salaire donc ses 1800
euros nets par mois et on nous dit
justement qui a pas assez d'argent pour
financer ce ses 1800 euros net par mois
eh bien nous on est pour couvrir
l'ouverture des livres de comptes la
transparence des comptes c'est que les
travailleurs et la population puisse
mettre leur nez dans les comptes et on
verrait qu'il ya de la voir continuer
avec un autre candidat sylvain gaga sont
pour pour lui père vous avez sur votre
site internet plusieurs points à
développer pour l'économie et réduire le
chômage notamment je cite l'allègement
des cotisations sociales patronales en
lien avec l'augmentation du
smic est ce que ces chiffres est par
exemple une telle proposition vous aussi
vous voulez aller à 1800 euros net par
mois ou ces différents j'ai plus
exactement le chiffre en tête mais on
veut en effet remonter le smic il me
semble que c'est plutôt aux alentours
des 1700 d'un côté on veut augmenter le
smic et pour et vivre pouvoir
contrebalancer d'un point de vue
financier on veut réduire en effet les
cotisations mais surtout sur l'épée les
pme et les tpe en fait aujourd'hui il ya
un gros problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les grosses sociétés en france ne paye
plus l'impôt donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
belle vue que l'assiette des dix minutes
en augmente on augmente sur les tpe les
pme
tous ces gens qui au final ne peuvent
pas se plaindre parce qu'ils n'ont pas
le fin voilà une société de trois
personnes qui fait grève
voilà y'a pas de problème donc
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui ça c'est
quand même un vrai un vrai un vrai sujet
le vrai sujet c'est que pendant les
trente glorieuses on a eu de plus en
plus d'acquis sociaux et ses acquis
sociaux il y avait aucun problème pour
les financer et aujourd'hui on a un
train de tous nous les enlever en nous
expliquant qu'on est trop cher la
question c'est mais où est-ce qu'on a
déraillé ou quand est ce qu'il ya eu un
problème pourquoi avant et ça marche et
ça ne marche plus maintenant j'invite
les gens à se renseigner notamment sur
maastricht ch depuis 92
il y a la possibilité pour les grandes
entreprises de faire des délocalisations
et létal interdiction d'interdire quand
même exceptionnel dans les traités on
voit rarement ça une interdiction
d'interdire et du coup toutes les
grandes sociétés peuvent envoyer leur
argent à l'étranger pour créer des
entreprises phares des entreprises non
des usines par exemple et l'état aussi
l'interdiction d'interdire le
rapatriement des biens créés à
l'étranger
donc si vous créez une usine notamment
on va prendre en chine pour prendre un
exemple mais on a des d'autres et même
des moins et remplace le temps le temps
des les comptes et je sais bien c'est
juste pour dire qu' on ne sera jamais
suffisamment compétitif vis-à-vis d'eux
c'est à dire que me dit il faudrait
casser le smic enlever les charges
sociales et faire disparaître l'état et
même avec tout ça je pense qu'on aurait
du mal à être compétitif alors vous êtes
déjà à trois minutes on enchaîne avec
françoise forette sur sur vos mesures
debout la france pau pour l'économie on
a l'impression que l'économie repart
légèrement est-ce que déjà c'est à
vensac --qui à propositions
qu'en tant que chef d'entreprise je ne
peux que vous dire que l'économie repart
c'est ce que j'ai constaté ces trois
derniers mois maintenant
je rejoins ce que disait monsieur savoir
que si les entreprises s'installent
enfin les entreprises françaises
délocalisent
je ne vois pas comment est-ce que ça
peut être producteur de richesse pour
nous et pour pour les travailleurs dans
la mesure où
les richesses qui sont envoyées à
l'étranger ne revienne pas en france
donc ça c'est un vrai souci comment on
fait pour les refaire moi je leur
mettrais des impôts moi si oui moi
jacques sereys jeu
mettrait un impôt pour les entreprises
qui comment dirais-je ne veulent pas
payer leurs impôts en france moi je les
obligerais à le faire jérémy bizet vous
voulez favoriser notamment le commerce
de proximité c'est votre proposition à
vous comment vous espérez faire cela si
vous allez à l'assemblée nationale d'un
point de vue général je souhaite
soutenir activement tous les commerces
de proximité acteurs locaux artisans tpe
pme effectivement comme ça a été dit
aujourd'hui les tpe/pme payent plus
d'impôts que les grandes entreprises ce
n'est pas normal il faut réussir à
remonter les impôts sur les grandes
entreprises
si qui aujourd'hui licencie c'est le cas
aujourd'hui profitent des salariés qui
en abusent et soutenir absolument est
véritablement les petites entreprises
afin qu'enfin elle puisse embaucher
soissons créatis d'excellence de lien
social
elles font vivre les villes et les
villages donc il faut absolument les
soutenir pour cela il faut baisser leurs
charges
je pense comparativement aux grandes
entreprises ensuite il faut redonner une
vision de l'agriculture paysanne
arrêtez de voir faire l'agriculture
intensive souvent polluantes et aider
les agriculteurs qui sont les premiers
protecteurs de l'environnement
ceux qui sont sous lé ter à pouvoir
produire de nouveau de façon plus local
plus paysanne donc il faut baisser la
tva sur les produits bio actuellement
elle à 5,5 pour cent pourrait l'abaisser
à devenir 2% maximum pour les produits
bio qu'ils soient français ou étrangers
et essayer dessous de proposer donc si
c'est difficile avec l'union européenne
actuelle que la tva des produits bio
vendus localement soit à 0%
ils sont de créer de l'emploi dans ce
domaine pascal casimir perier votre
vision de l'emploi vous vous soutenez
emmanuel macron vos soutenait aussi la
réforme qui souhaitent mettre en place
notamment du code du travail par exemple
oui bien sûr d'eux
si vous voulez pour la circonscription
j'ai deux propositions la première c'est
les créer un label circuits courts label
circuits courts c'est tout simple en
fait quand vous fabriquer un produit en
moins de cent kilomètres
l'un d'eux consommateurs qu ils achètent
il a une baisse de la tva de 5%
du coup le produit il est moins cher du
coup ça vous incite à l'acheter et pour
les services par exemple prenez un
menuisier vous faites une limite autour
de 30 kilomètres donc par exemple quand
vous avez un travail de menuiserie à
faire et bien de menuisier de votre
village il devient plus compétitif donc
vous protégez votre emploi ou vous
faites une économiste donc c'est bon
pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est bon pour l'environnement parce
qu'il ya moins de transport donc tout le
monde est gagnant
alors j'ai un très bel exemple ça c'est
moi qui les fais c'est cinéma circulaire
cette circulaire je les fait à vélizy et
j'ai eu le document de mon adversaire
monsieur n'avons pas répondre ça dommage
mais les gens pourront vérifier vous
regardez en fait sur le côté il ya un
petit rcsc le rcs en fait vous allez sur
societe.com vous tapez sur cs et vous
allez voir où était imprimé ce document
s'est imprimée au puy-en-velay donc ça
c'est en fait tout ce qu'il faut pas
faire en france en france oui mais c'est
en france mais c'est à 600 km donc si
vous voulez développer l'emploi dans la
circonscription alors ça va ce combat
allait se sont conscient quelqu'un qui
n'est pas en plateau puisque du coup il
ne peut pas répondre
ils y répondront aux électeurs et puis
dans les urnes y'a pas de problème on va
on va on va poursuivre avec françoise
foraine puisque vous avez un petit peu
de retard sur le temps de parole on a
parlé des circuits courts du commerce de
proximité ce que vous avez par exemple
des thématiques et des propositions sur
ces sujets là pour les aider face aux
grandes surfaces par exemple
donc en tant que chef d'entreprise
petites entreprises
je suis favorable bien entendu à tous
qui est circuits courts et en
particulier les petits commerces
les petits commerces de proximité ce qui
vont être là par 24 heures sur 24 mais
presque et qui sont vraiment à l'écouté
de nos concitoyens c'est pas comme dans
une grande surface où vous allez faire
vos courses et il n'y aura personne
donc c'est très important d'avoir ce ce
panel de deux commerçants pour nos
concitoyens
donc déjà il faut savoir que pour tout
ce qui est comment dirais-je légumes etc
et produits certains produits
alimentaires dans notre secteur il y a
des des comment dirais-je desjardins où
nous avons la possibilité d'accueillir
et de recevoir ce type de service
aujourd'hui ce qui serait bien c'est de
pouvoir les mettre davantage en avant
leur donner beaucoup plus de visibilité
mais c'est pas un député qui peuvent
faire ça il faut aussi que ce soit l'un
s'en est peut-être impulser une voilà
c'est cela monsieur impulsé cette idée
là pour pouvoir promouvoir le
savoir-faire en france mais avec la
création de mon label c'est quoi ce
monde tout à fait à cette solution
on va on va on va peut-être regarder vos
temps de parole qui vont s'afficher très
bientôt pour pour voir si l'or alors on
va on va voir le ton par vous vous
souhaitez poursuivre le dessus peut-être
mais on va voir peut-être des temps de
parole s'afficher à l'instant vous les
voyez
du coup un peu de retard pour jérémy
bizet c'était vous qui parlait justement
pendant que vous l'avez fléchi les temps
de parole ça vous laisse quelques
secondes pour conclure sur ce suivi puis
on parlera des transports ensuite vous
souhaitiez peut-être ajouter quelque
chose très rapidement très rapidement
parce qu'elle parlait de
son label mais il est locale et locales
familier de voir au niveau national il
sera le local mais pour valable pour
toute la france
donc c'est pas nous c'est pas le cas
non non vous favorise le vous habitez à
maurice le local d'habitat versailles
vous acheter non mais j'ai un service à
versailles vous avez 5 % de baisse de
terreur c'est celle là vous êtes à lyon
vous commander un produit au puy en
velay par hasard c'est un label vous
faites une économie de 5 %
quand vous achetez le produit qui est
fabriqué au plan d'eau hélène janisset
vous souhaitiez aussi réagir alors très
rapidement puisque oui sinon vous aurez
moins de temps sur la partie suivante
brièvement sur le parce que je t'aime
c'est quand même l'emploi mais ça fait
une quarantaine d'années maintenant que
tous les partis qui se sont succédé aux
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
ont expliqué qu'il fallait aider les
entreprises baisser et ce sont des
dizaines de milliards d'argent public
qui ont été versés aux entreprises sous
forme de crédit d'impôt de baisse de
cotisation on nous a expliqué que
c'était ça qui allait permettre de
lutter contre le chômage
cet argent a été versé à fonds perdus et
juste cet argent il aurait été beaucoup
plus utile si l'état s'en était servi
justement pour créer des emplois dans
tous les services publics où il en
manque cruellement que ce soit les
hôpitaux l'éducation les transports et
une aurait permis aussi de construire
les logements dans les travailleurs ont
besoin
on est à vingt minutes d'émission vous
avez du coup un peu d'avancé maintenant
on va enchaîner avec la deuxième
thématique elle les transports sujets
importants surtout en ile de france
surtout en grande couronne on connaît
les problèmes qu'ils soient sur la route
les problèmes dans les transports en
commun la pollution aussi sylvain
gargasson est-ce que vous avez vous des
priorités pour les transports pour les
transports en ile-de-france pour
améliorer la vie que ce soit soit des
automobilistes soient des transports des
en commun des usagers des transports en
commun ou la pollution alors c'est
relativement peu le travail d'un député
plus pour la voiture on va dire mais
pour les transports en commun notamment
savez que c'est plus le ministère du
transport ainsi que les queue leu leu
comment s'appelle la limite le député va
voter le financement je me permets de
dire ça parce que j'ai entendu pas mal
de choses les jours et en revenir sur ce
que beaucoup de gens ne savent pas ce
qu'est un député donc un député c'est un
député de la nation se dire qu'il n'est
pas là pour défendre sa circonscription
il est là pour voter des lois qui
s'appliqueront au niveau national le
député il est là pour préparer les lois
et les voter il est pas là pour voilà
essayer d'améliorer les transports à
paris il va être là pour améliorer les
transports de façon globale il y aurait
notamment beaucoup de choses à dire on
parler de la pollution
voilà nous on pense que dans l'union
européenne le fait que les barrières
soient complètement descendu bah ça fait
un afflux massif de pollution quand vous
faites venir tous vos produits de chine
du bangladesh ou autre il ya un moment
on le paye forcément quelque part sur la
facture la facture co2 donc je pense que
tout ça c'est des sujets qui sont très
intéressants j'ai entendu dire qu'il y
avait des preuves des problèmes dans
cette europe là j'en suis tout à fait je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça sauf
que moi je dis pas qu'il ya un problème
avec cette europe là je dis que cette
europe là n'est pas arrivé par hasard
est qu'elle n'est pas réformable
parce qu'il faut l'unanimité des 28
états pour changer les traités et que
par exemple si demain vous voulez
empêcher les délocalisations
un pays comme enfin n'importe quel pays
de l'est va vous dire non puisque en
bénéficient à plein voilà françoise
forette j'avais misé sur sur les
transports ont semblé acquiescer la
pollution qui venait qui venaient de
chine votre position là dessus
oui tout à fait maintenant moi je trouve
ce qui serait bien c'est de développer
le ferroutage mais c'est pareil ça ne
relève pas du tout
du député saleh jeu bien sûr sinon comme
on les aime mais finalement tout a
failli à deux ça aussi mais on ne peut
donner qu'une impulsion c'est pas un
député qui va faire changer changer les
choses
et là c'est comme ça il ya un projet par
exemple important sur la 2e
circonscription c'est la ligne 18 et
vous pouvez par exemple porter ce projet
bien si pour le bloquer parce que vous
l'estimez bombay pour le territoire
votre position à vous par exemple sur la
ligne 18 qui fait partie du grand paris
express
moi je suis favorable à tout ce qui est
je dirais désengorgement des villes et
des campagnes mais il ne faut pas non
plus que sai altérer les villes et les
campagnes si elles sont impactées par
une une autoroute qui va qui va passer
s'il faut un
il est important à ce moment là de
consulter les gens et de ne pas le faire
à l'emporte-pièce ou parent une décision
arbitraire jérémy bizet j'imagine que
c'est un sujet qui vous tient à coeur
vous avez un petit peu de retard donc
vous pouvez peut-être développer votre
point de vue votre priorité à vous par
exemple pour les transports elle se
situe où je vais venir jouer juste
revenir sur un point qui avait dit
monsieur un député et un effectivement
un élu de la nation
mais imaginez demain que les 577 députés
soient nés et toujours vécu à paris leur
ancrage territorial leur expérience de
là où ils ont vécu est extrêmement
important je pense pour les décisions
qu'ils comprendre donc c'est un mandat
national mais je pense que avoir un
député qui se connaissent à sa
conception soit très important je pense
après c'est un débat qu'on pourrait vous
pouvez réagir à chaque fois c'est un peu
comme ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
il ya des députés qui vont essayer de
pousser des projets d'autres de les
freiner
bah c'est dommage nous ce qu'on leur
demande c'est déjà d'analyser un petit
peu la société puisqu'on n'a pas besoin
d'habiter à versailles par exemple pour
en connaître pour connaître les maires
voile jt pour pourquoi être la ruralité
et s'en est jamais avant foutu les pieds
non ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
déjà l'état donne des moyens d' analyse
ensuite de sa normalement un député
n'est pas là pour pousser un projet ou
essayer de le torpiller dans l'ombre il
est là pour siéger à l'assemblée voté
les ans il connaît le terrain il pourra
mieux défendre ou non le projet global
mais un député n'est pas un super mais
où un super conseiller général non mais
députés ont été chauds sur les
transports j'aime c'est un peu le temps
d'exposer notre point de vue pascal à
casimir perier ensuite et puis on
enchaînera avec violaine janis est allé
sur les transports moi justement c'est
mon côté écologiste réaliste je souhaite
c'est retrouver soutenait avec transport
en commun et si les développer il faut
aussi de comprendre les pratiques des
gens locaux
je pense qu'il ya pas de parkings
gratuits auprès des gars voulaient aller
à paris à saint rémy les chevreuse
le parking est payant c'est rambouillet
si l'on continue en dehors de la
circonscription c'est payant est
impossible de trouver une place
donc comment encourager les gens à
prendre les transports qui sont déjà
surchargés si en plus ils peuvent pas se
garer
ce faux bien accéder n'y a pas assez de
bus pour tout le monde ensuite il faut
soutenir l'achat de véhicules propres
donc les gens puissent ça peut prendre
la voiture mais avec un véhicule propre
et gpl et hybrides électriques aider les
entreprises qui veulent faire des
véhicules électriques pouvant faire plus
de 200 km ensuite il faut trouver des
solutions pour désengorger les routes ni
les transports en commun sont bleues
sont surchargés les routes aussi je suis
via c'est ma ville je travaille à paris
tous les matins je prends l'autoroute
a13 et je suis bloqué les automobiles
sont les premiers à subir cette
pollution
donc on peut être écologiste est aussi
prendre en considération que les gens
qui sont les bouchons ils font pas ça
par pur plaisir de fouiller 2/3 des
solutions aussi sur la route et impulser
les régions pour 6,3 des solutions pour
désengorger les routes comme l'a 13 218
etc
pascal casimir perier notre point de vue
à vous sur les soirs ans portant son
attention sur les députés la prochaine
fois peut-être sur moi alors sur sur le
transport donc je suis chez nous la
problématique dans circonscription ses
embouteillages
donc il
pour plaisanter la solution c'est la
voiture volante il vient d'être inventé
donc là on passe au dessus de tout le
monde il ya plus de problème mais sinon
concrètement à la bonne solution c'est
du kuweit ouvrage de par rapport au lieu
de travail blaquart a mis ça en place
très récemment ça va commencer à se
développer et si vous voulez vous rendez
compte que vous habitez à manille et
puis vous allez travailler
mettant à versailles et puis votre
voisin il travaille pas dans votre
entreprise mais il travaille juste à
côté et donc ou des fois vous avez les
mêmes créneaux donc là bas car met en
place des horaires et vous pouvez encore
réserver une voiture après vous avez le
partage des véhicules comme les vélib
des commandites les autolib à paris
donc c'est une bonne solution parce que
quand les personnes ont besoin de
voiture et prennent aux voitures
électriques
ponctuellement et ça répond à leurs
besoins du coup les parisiens qui n'ont
pas forcément de voiture ils achètent
plus de voiture donc on a des solutions
le tramway c'est aussi une solution
intéressante parce que c'est fiable ça
fait pas de bruit c'est régulier le
tramway qui est installé à vélizy sait
très bien qui chez nous il ya une grosse
problématique c'est l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble
avec le bruit donc là si je suis élue
députée j'essaierai d'imposer le fait de
mettre des silencieux sur tous les
avions entoure toute la france pour que
les avions c'est pas un problème qui
décollent ou atterrissent
c'est le bruit qui dérange hélène janis
et vous avez désormais vous plus de
retard que les autres vous n'êtes pas
intervenue sur ce sujet des transports
vous défendez les travailleurs c'est
généralement ceux qui ont le moins
d'argent donc les plus on va dire c'est
qu'ils galèrent le plus sans doute dans
les trois là qu'est ce qu'on fait du
coup telle est votre priorité si vous
êtes député pour sujet vous allez porter
à l'assemblée nationale ce que je veux
dire c'est que les transports
effectivement c'est le lot quotidien de
millions de travailleurs et que la
plupart vivent dans les banlieues de
plus en plus éloignés des de paris par
exemple et que ça c'est pas comment
c'est pas c'est pas une fatalité non
plus parce que c'est aussi le fruit vous
savez de l'organisation de la société
parce que quand même ceux qui organisent
la société ceux qui la dirigent il la
dirige dans leurs seuls dans leurs seuls
intérêts individuels et quand il se
penche sur un problème quand il reste
veulent résoudre à leur façon ils
déplacent les travailleurs et les loges
il crée des logements décidé mais de
plus en plus loin des c'est ça le
problème c'est l'organisation sociale de
la société
alors je finis enfin juste et
l'organisation sociale de la société et
et nous on pense que justement c'est
remettre à plat cette organisation
sociale sera quand même indispensable
mais ceci dit tout à l'heure je disais
que l'état justement les collectivités
locales par tout un tas de biais ils
versent des milliards de subventions de
tout l'argent public est versée à fonds
perdus aux grandes entreprises
je pense qu'il serait plus utile à
développer justement tous les services
publics qui sont indispensables à la
population mais ce soit les transports
que ce soit pour la santé que ce soit
pour les écoles ça soit pour les bureaux
de poste alors vous allez répondre et
puis comme ça on va avoir le temps de
mettre à jour les temps de parole pour
vérifier les universités dans la ville
nouvelle en fait tu n'existais pas elle
a été écrit à peu près 30 ans on a créé
des infrastructures des transports et
des entreprises sont venues à côté et la
politique de la ville nouvelle
c'était de faire venir des grands
groupes c'est pour ça que sur les villes
nouvelles vous aider des grands groupes
de ce2 des sièges sociaux qui sont
installés sur la ville nouvelle
donc là en fait c'est ce que vous dites
bah on l'a fait et on l'a fait très bien
sur la ville nouvelle et on est un
choeur d'emploi et on est un choeur où
les habitants et on a su conserver notre
poumon vert avec la proximité du parc
naturel plus des espaces verts et des
entreprises alors on est déjà à 30
minutes d'émission on va passer à la
carte blanche le sujet que vous
souhaitez mettre en avant on voit aussi
peut-être voir vos temps de parole pour
voir comment vous allez calibré cette
carte blanche certains vont devoir
peut-être plus parler d'autres moi on va
le voir tout de suite à l'écran dans
quelques secondes voilà on les voit
jérémy bizet un peu de retard françoise
florelle un peu de retard aussi
hélène janis est aussi on commence avec
vous la candidate du coup de boule à
france vous avez pas mal de temps pour
exposer le point de ce point de vue la
thématique que vous souhaitez mettre en
avant alors ce que je souhaite mettre en
avant c'est la famille la famille au
sens au sens large
inclure dans la famille ce qui est
aujourd'hui devenu des cas qui ne sont
pas spécifiques les familles recomposées
aujourd'hui on a tendance à dire la
famille c'est un modèle comme ci comme
ça où je lui non ce n'est plus
aujourd'hui la famille est complètement
repositionné
ce qui serait bien c'est de pouvoir
accorder aux familles monoparentales
voilà aux familles monoparentales la
possibilité d'avoir des allocations
familiales qui soit j'ai envie de dire
descente
lorsqu'elles ont un seul enfant
aujourd'hui ce qui est pris en compte
c'est les familles qui ont plusieurs
enfants
mais ce qu'il ne faut pas oublier c'est
que dans la france d'aujourd'hui il ya
des familles qui n'ont qu'un seul enfant
et qui ont peu de moyens dont pourquoi
ne pas revaloriser cette cette catégorie
de population et ne pas les mettre à
l'index comme c'est fait si souvent
jérémy bizet vous étiez le deuxième le
plus en retard donc aussi pas mal de
temps pour exposer votre thématique
votre choix vous face aux électeurs qui
me regarde moi la thématique que je
souhaiterais aborder c'est la question
de la moralisation de la vie politique
et de replacer les citoyens au coeur de
la vie politique
c'est ce qu'on ressent de plus en plus
aujourd'hui par le vote tous les
mouvements citoyens sont plus en plus
nombreux malheureusement divisé les
mouvements citoyens les écologistes
indépendants
toutes ces causes qui me semble le noble
se dispersent et je souhaite aujourd'hui
essayer de rassembler l'ensemble des
gens des citoyens qui souhaitent une
faire une politique différente des gens
qui travaillent des gens qui connaissent
la vie des gens qui se mobilisent des
gens qui sont sur le terrain
je souhaite par exemple qu'on
reconnaisse le vote blanc je souhaite
qu'on puisse réellement mettre en place
le référendum d'initiative populaire
je suis d'accord avec ce que proposait
debout la france et l'ue pair avec le
casier judiciaire vierge
c'est vrai une base c'est tout le moins
tolérable qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
puisse être élu de la république est
d'avoir des peines
son casier judiciaire c'est on vient à
beaucoup que serait puis l'eau
aujourd'hui sinon donc ça serait
peut-être pas pu rêver prendra corps bah
ça on est tous des mouillages politique
va être révolutionné au delà de la dose
idées nos divergences on est tous des
citoyens ont tous capables de se parler
donc tous cas pas vraiment des défunts
d'accord heureusement heureusement on
arrive à 34 minutes d'émission hélène
janis et votre carte blanche à vous pour
lutte ouvrière le point que vous
souhaitez mettre en avant plus
rapidement que les deux candidats
d'avoir s'il vous plaît mais je voudrais
m'adresser aux travailleurs qui nous
écoutent et plus particulièrement à ceux
qui trop nombreux sont tentés par
le vote du front national et se laissent
piéger justement par les idées qu'ils
divulguent on essaye de nous dresser les
essais de dresser les travailleurs les
uns contre les autres en montrant du
doigt celui qui est au chômage ou en
montrant du doigt les travailleurs
immigrés qui serait responsable de tous
les maux mais c'est une façon de vouloir
masquer que les vrais responsables de
tous les maux dans la société ce sont
les capitalistes et en fait ils sont
dans leur camp et ce sont des ennemis
mortels de la classe ouvrière et moi je
suis le vote lutte ouvrière le vote pour
ma candidature c'est de voter justement
pour cent quand d'affirmer que la classe
ouvrière on est quelles que soient nos
origines une autre nationalité en une
seule classe ouvrière on a un combat
commun mené contre un ennemi comme
pascal à casimir perier très rapidement
puisque vous avez plus parler vraiment
quelques secondes
et puis ce sera pareil pour ce garçon
pour conclure cette émission s'il vous
plaît alors l'objectif de cette élection
législative c'est quand même de donner
la possibilité à meymac ronde gouverner
donc il faut absolument qu'il ait une
majorité une majorité forte à
l'assemblée nationale pour qu'ils
puissent passer son programme
alors moi à titre personnel je serais un
député fidèle à emmanuel macron pas du
tout frondeur et par contre je serais le
nouveau monsieur propre de l'assemblée
nationale voilà c'est ça mon ski est
important il faut que l'on réconcilier
la france avec une moralisation de la
vie politique et donc moi aussi j'ai un
casier judiciaire vierge mettrait sur
mon blog
ah voilà à toutes et à tous les trois un
art encore et moi je vais je aller
encore plus loin c'est dire que moi je
me suis engagé sur mon programme a
baissé mon salaire
donc mon salaire actuellement si je suis
élu député il est de 7200 euros
je me passerais à 5000 euros et les 2200
euros d'économie je les donnerai mes pas
moins personnellement ce sera
l'assemblée nationale qui est donnera
une association d'aidé au logement
merci on termine avec silva gargasson
très rapidement un peu plus rapidement
s'il vous plaît pascal casimir perier
alors on sait que c'est difficile eh
bien bon d'enfoncer cloud une dernière
fois la cie siar vierge
je rappellerai qu'aujourd'hui pour être
taxi ou facteurs il vous faut un quasi
lui un casier vierge c'est quand même
incroyable que pourra écrire les lois et
les voter y en ai pas besoin
écoutez il y aura encore cent mille
choses à dire je pense que le mieux
c'est que je renvoie vos téléspectateurs
sur notre site upr point fr où ils
retrouveront toutes nos analyses des
vidéos régulière sur l'actualité des
longues conférence pour expliquer les
griefs que l'on a vis à vis de l'union
européenne de l'euro et de l'otan parce
que c'est pas une idée qui a germé comme
ça et je vous donnais à vous remercier
en tout cas parce que il n'ya plus que
les petits médias qui jouent encore leur
rôle démocratique et à chaque fois tv
fil 78 et yveline premières ont toujours
participé donc je tiens vous tirer le
chapeau
merci à vous s'inquiètent revenu puis je
renvoie les électeurs pour aller plus
loin sur vos sites internet respectifs
de mon parti merci d'être venus en
plateau tout de suite les derniers
candidats de cette 2e circonscription
des yvelines seront en plateau avec nous
tout de suite un sujet de mélanie poké
qui vous présente les enjeux de ce
territoire
de retour dans les bureaux de vote
un an plus tard la deuxième
circonscription des yvelines a connu en
mars 2016 une législative partielle
suite à la démission de valérie pécresse
élue à la présidence de la région ile de
france le 20 mars 2016 c'est pascal
thévenot qui est élu député avec 72% des
voix mais avec seulement 26 % de
participation
l'élu les républicains remet son mandat
en jeu avec l'étiquette de favori
la circonscription est
traditionnellement ancrée à droite 17
candidats se sont déclarés pour le
premier tour du 11 juin prochain
le principal adversaire du candidat les
républicains pourrait être jean noël
barrot
l'enseignant chercheur de 34 ans est
actuellement conseiller départemental de
haute loire à la rentrée prochaine et
rejoindra le campus hec de jouy-en-josas
le candidat est investi pour cette
législative par la république en marche
partie des manuels macron mais celui qui
pourrait ravir des voix pascal thévenot
c'est pascale poirot le candidat divers
droite est soutenu par le parti chrétien
démocrate
il se présente pour la première fois
lors de la partielle de 2016 benjamin
lac ont soutenu lui aussi par le pcd
avait obtenu 9
56% des suffrages autre prétendant le
front national représenté par yasmine
belmadi actuelle conseillère régionale
d'île de france
le parti espère réitérer le score de
2016 où il était arrivé 4e et avait
obtenu 9 38% des voix
à noter que dans cette circonscription
le parti socialiste a trouvé un accord
avec europe ecologie les verts et le
parti radical de gauche pour ne
présenter qu'un seul candidat
et c'est l'avocat tanguy ruellan qui a
été choisie nouveau parti créé lors de
la présidentielle france insoumise a
aussi son candidat
l'écrivain metteur en scène et acteur
marc soriano est un fidèle de la
première heure de jean-luc mélenchon
onze candidats sont aussi dans la course
axel brunet candidat divers gauche
christophe qui sied pour le parti des
animalistes jérémy biz est déjà candidat
en 2016 pour france écologie pascal
casimir perier gilles porte le voit
françoise florelle céline julier
emmanuel 2,20 hélène janis et jean-guy
sayus et sylvain gargasson le 11 juin
prochain plus de 85 mille inscrits sont
appelés à glisser leur bulletin dans
l'urne
on poursuit on termine ce débat avec six
nouveaux candidats les derniers vous
avez eu le temps j'imagine de voir ce
qui se passait et comprendre le déroulé
de l'émission votre temps de parole je
leur précise sera chronométrée on fera
plusieurs points pendant l'émission que
vous pouvez si vous le souhaitez
répondre aussi à vos interlocuteurs et
puis les six candidats avec moisson
jean-guy sayus candidat divers-droite
membres notamment du mouvement 100%
citoyens christophe pélissier candidat
écologiste investi par le parti
animalistes axel brunet candidat
divers-gauche investi par le mouvement
des progressistes gilles pour le voit
candidat divers gauche investi par
nouvelle donne céline julier candidate
extrême droite investi par le parti
souveraineté identité et libertés et
enfin cyril henri candidats suppléants
en des manuels de vin divers-droite et
investit là par alliance royale
bonsoir à tous les six mêmes questions
qu aux autres candidats pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance en voir reprendre l'ordre de
présentation j'en dis ça use pourquoi
les électeurs de
vous faire confiance le 11 juin prochain
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier de
m'avoir invité à ce débat mme alors
pourquoi ce que les électeurs doivent me
faire confiance
le 11 juin prochain en fait je me
présente rapidement donc je suis jean
guy saliou j'habite en vallée de
chevreuse achèverait c'est très
précisément je connais bien cette
circonscription la 2e circonscription
pour l'avoir pratiqué dans différents
contextes professionnels et extra
professionnelles et je connais bien les
circonscriptions environnantes la une
des spécificités de cette
circonscription c'est qu'elle est
localisée sur trois communautés de
communes ou intercommunalités que c'est
que ce qui l'amène de fait du coup à
fréquenter un petit peu tout le monde
quoi en fait j'étais élu sur cette
circonscription si à une époque de ma
vie
donc pourquoi est ce que les électeurs
devrait me faire confiance et bien
simplement parce qu'ils vont avoir à se
faire confiance eux mêmes en fait moi je
me propose de sur une sur je me propose
mon engagement se situe sur une ligne
une relativement spécifique puisque ce
que je cherche à proposer
c'est de changer les règles du jeu du
fonctionnement de deux de nos pratiques
politiques et de nos institutions pour
aller vers ce que l'on connaît dans
berlin endroit donc où les citoyens
apprécient
et sont fiers des systèmes qui vivent je
pense à la suisse et l'allemagne
et j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure merci
beaucoup christophe pélissier pour le
parti animalistes même question pourquoi
les électeurs devraient vous faire
confiance doit vous faire confiance
d'accord alors déjà je vais présenter un
peu le parti animalistes puisque c'est
un nouveau parti en france dont le but
est de faire émerger la question animale
dans le champ politique aujourd'hui
c'est un parti par contre qu'il s'est
déjà l'international puisqu'il est
présent dans de nombreux pays notamment
aux pays bas où il ya plusieurs élus
ainsi qu'au portugal ou en australie par
exemple
en fait la cause animale est un sujet
qui me tient à coeur
comme de nombreux français il ya de plus
en plus de vidéos notamment de
l'association l214 qui montre des images
abominables des conditions des animaux
dans les abattoirs dans les élevages
beaucoup de d'image choquant aujourd'hui
on en à 2017
il ya toujours la corrida on autorise
toujours les cirques avec des animaux on
tue des animaux pour leur fourrure
autant de choses qui sont plus
supportables aujourd'hui est donc le
parti adema liste a été créé pour ça
pour faire prendre conscience aux
grandes familles politiques au
gouvernement qu'il y a tout un électorat
qui sait plus possible et pour montrer
que la cause animale n'est pas un sujet
périphériques ou secondaire mais que
c'est vraiment une priorité à prendre en
compte axel brunet pour le mouvement des
progressistes excusez-moi j'ai excusez
moi ça fait ça fait longtemps qu'on est
en plateau maintenant avec cette volée
excusez moi pour le mouvement des
progressistes où il fait chaud pourquoi
les les électeurs doivent t'ils vous
faire confiance
bonjour tout c'est tous et merci de
hâter les fils 110,2 un temps de parole
à tous les candidats
alors voilà pourquoi je me présente je
me présente pour
montrer une volonté de renouveau
politique dans le champ politique
français de porter à l'assemblée
nationale quelqu'un qui vient
du peuple puisque l'assemblée nationale
c'est d'abord l'assemblée populaire
l'assemblée de la population française
est coupée avec tous ceux qui siègent
actuellement qui sont complètement
coupés des réalités du terrain qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui tous les jours
donc je porte les idées du mouvement des
progressistes dans lequel je me retrouve
complètement qui souhaitent monter une
majorité parlementaire pour avoir une
majorité parlementaire plurielle et
pousser les idées progressistes de notre
mouvement que nous défendrons notre
seule ambition c'est d'améliorer la vie
quotidienne de chacun de tous les jours
de trouver des solutions à ce que nous
vivons et tout cela dans une politique
environnementale respectueuse de
l'écologie cette fois ci je me tourne
vraiment en verve il pas on le voit
pourquoi les électeurs doivent t'ils
vous faire confiance alors il faut pas
toucher les micros voilà au beau trop
tard
voilà vous le saurez pour la suite de
l'émission et sachez d'ailleurs que je
vous précise déjà les candidats les plus
bavards donc on aura peu de temps pour
parler les sujets notamment l'emploi
gilles pour le voir pourquoi les
électeurs de style vous faire confiance
parce que je manipule vient de micros
nous allons déjà si vous y tenir donc je
vais présenter un petit peu nouvelle
donne puisque c'est surtout pour
nouvelle donne que ses électeurs doivent
voter donc c'est un parti assez récent
il date de fin 2013 on a participé aux
européennes en 2014
quelques sélections départementales et
régionales pas partout en france on
continue
essayer de partager nos idées avec les
citoyens à travers les élections cette
fois-ci législatives donc on se
distinguer on a commencé parce qu'on
apportait des idées nouvelles entre
guillemets le partage du temps de
travail qui est très ancien mais qui en
fait avait été oubliée redevenait
nouveau la transition écologique qui
était portée par les écologistes mais
que tu as un peu oublié maintenant
toutes ces idées enfin ces deux idées
majeures on voit ils sont reprises par
pas mal de parti benoît hamon la veille
dans son programme la france est soumise
il a également dans son programme mais
c'est déjà une première victoire mais je
pense que les électeurs peuvent être
intéressés de continuer à soutenir
nouvelle donne qui a apporté quelque
chose dans le débat céline julier c'est
votre tour pourquoi les électeurs
doivent t'ils vais faire confiance pour
représenter le parti ciel voilà alors
bonsoir monsieur alors tout d'abord je
récuse l'appellation d'extrême droite ça
me surprend beaucoup pour être honnête
je pense que je défende et des
convictions qui sont oui tout à fait
mais c'est de la profession à la
préfecture la préfecture c'est des
services préfectoraux et donc là on
défend des idées et donc cette
classification que des personnes ont
décidé de faire sur telle ou telle idée
moi je la récuse je considère que j'ai
des idées de droite je suis quelqu'un
d'enraciner je défends mes idées et je
n'ai pas du tout eu honte mais
simplement cette appellation d'extrême
droite aujourd'hui est presque un
sobriquet en tout cas c'est ça me paraît
une critique donc j'assume je suis de
droite mais j'ai envie de dire divers
droite et les idées que je défends sont
des idées que vous retrouviez dans les
programmes des grands partis de droite
comme le rpr il ya dix quinze ans mais
mes idées sont bien sûr des idées
d'actualité je vais les développer
pourquoi s'y font voter pour nous
aujourd'hui
et bien parce que la france souffre et
je pense que le ciel le parti du ciel
souveraineté identité liberté à bien
identifier les problèmes de la france
aujourd'hui
et finalement ils sont sur deux plans
essentiellement c'est un problème
aujourd'hui de déliquescence morale dont
chacun souffre aujourd'hui on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une inflation de la
réglementation parce que les gens n'ont
plus en eux mêmes la capacité de se
réfréner
de se comporter correctement en
respectant les autres et c'est pour ça
que vous avez des réglementations
partout voilà et le deuxième la deuxième
grande problématique qu'on retrouve en
france et dont les gens souffrent
terriblement aujourd'hui c'est
l'identité dans le fond qui sommes nous
qui sont les français et c'est cette
identité là que nous voudrions défendre
transmettre par une école restaurer que
nous voudrions également porter
éventuellement l'étranger je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une sorte de
haine de soi une espèce d'injonction il
faudrait qu'on ait honte
donc nous nous avons un beau pays une
belle histoire et cesti cette histoire
et ses racines chrétiennes et françaises
que nous voulons porter alors avant de
vous donner la parole cyril henri
recueilli un tout petit peu parce que
vous êtes dans le fond on ne voit pas
monsieur henri et monsieur henri
faudrait récupérer un petit peu votre
micro le tournant trou de voilà entre
vous deux c'est parfait ce que vous vous
partagez un micro on a un petit souci de
micro nous vous partager le micro à
chaque fois vous tendre un peu pourquoi
les électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance vous représenter le parti
alliance royale
alors me faire confiance je ne sais pas
c'est un bien grand mot en tout cas je
voudrais les convaincre que la situation
actuelle de crise qui vient d'être
décrite et quand je crois sur lequel
tout le monde est d'accord
elle n'est pas le fruit du hasard elle
le fruit d'une politique d'une action
qui remonte au moins 40 à 50 ans avec
une grande constance départit pas il ya
une alternance
les politiques ne changent pas donc il
ya un cadre il ya un cadre il ya il ya
tout un contexte intellectuel et
culturel qui font que bah on va toujours
dans la même direction il regarde pas
ailleurs je crois qu'il faut sortir du
cadre et donc notre but c'est d'inviter
les français à reporter la question des
institutions comme quand une entreprise
se réorganise pour être plus efficace et
bien il faut que la france réorganise
ses institutions pour pouvoir prendre
les bonnes décisions et choisir les
bonnes personnes
ce qu il ne se passe pas actuellement
alors on ne va pas forcément parler
d'institutions ce soir notre première
thématique c'est l'emploi françois
hollande avait promis en son temps
d'inverser la courbe du chômage elle
peine elle commence à le faire depuis
quelques mois
si vous êtes dans quelques jours député
qu'est ce que vous ferez pour m pour
permettre de relancer la machine emploi
je me tourne vers ses lignes vulliez
pour commencer sur le site internet
votre parti que j'ai été voir
montpellier il faut libérer nos pme tpe
et agriculteurs notamment du carcan
administratif et matraquage fiscal vous
êtes donc pour un abaissement des impôts
mais oui je suis pour je suis pour un
abaissement des impôts je suis surtout
pour un abaissement des dépenses je
pense que le jour où on en arrivera à
par exemple le nombre de fonctionnaires
je n'ai rien contre les fonctionnaires
mais il est évident qu'on est le premier
pays d'europe
c'est une charge terrible pour les
entreprises spécialement pour les tpe
pme
on aura fait un grand pas mais surtout
je crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui un carcan
européen qui est insupportable pour
beaucoup de gens tout le monde se plaint
il ya une inflation de la réglementation
européenne qui empêche les gens d'avancé
ça empêche de monter une entreprise
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui a envie de
monter mais il hésite à monter une
entreprise je trouve ça dramatique donc
sa place
l'envy de de se lancer donc il ya
l'europe qui nous bride
il ya aussi le manque de compétitivité
puisque l'euro créé une asymétrie entre
les différents pays vous avez la 1re
mathilde des travailleurs détachés
puisque vous pouvez aujourd'hui faire
travailler un polonais en payant des
charges peu le des charges au niveau de
la pologne mais ils travaillent en
france dont finalement tout ça ça plombe
si vous voulez l'économie française on
n'a plus les moyens de se défendre
il faut également par exemple et
rétablir une préférence nationale ça me
paraît nécessaire pour les agriculteurs
moi je suis fille d'agriculteur
j'entends qu'il ya des suicides
d'agriculteurs ça n'est plus tenable
il faut absolument rétablir une
protection du travail français en france
est empêchée aussi les jeunes de partir
à l'étranger nos jeunes qui sont bien
formés il faut absolument leur donner
des raisons de rester en france
gilles pour le voit nouvelles donnes
classé à gauche politiquement propose
aussi de protéger les pme et sur le site
internet est aussi je me réfère au site
internet
il est inscrit qu'il est possible de
diviser par deux le nombre de chômeurs
est ce que alors ça va être très
compliqué mais rapidement m'expliquer
quelques recettes pour ça donc c'est une
phrase magique effectivement inné c'est
pas avec une seule action que l'on
pourra diminuer
les chauffeurs cette façon là c'est une
somme d'actions diverses et variées
alors si on n'est pas senti peu en revue
on a notre adn comme on l'appelle qui
est le partage du travail puisque
l'automatisation des cotisations la
productivité ont des effets néfastes sur
la quantité de travail partageable la
transition écologique auquel on tient
beaucoup
que ce soit à l'isolation des bâtiments
que ça soit la construction
l'installation de matériel pour
l'énergie renouvelable
ce sont déjà des actions qui devraient
développer l'emploi ou du moins
permettre de le partager
on a aussi un sujet avec le dumping
social européen qui effectivement amène
ce problème évoqué par rapport à madame
mais c'est pas les travailleurs qu'il
faut accablé c'est effectivement il
faudrait monter
les salaires de l'autre côté de nos
frontières afin que la concurrence soit
soit loyale le cicr n'a pas été
forcément de bonnes mesures puisque
puisqu'on n'a pas été payée de pme
traiter les tpe/pme de la même façon que
le cac 40 s'est sûrement pas une bonne
idée
il ya d'autres solutions pour tpe/pme
accès le bruit on enchaîne parce que le
temps de parole c'est cool c'est cool
vite
quels sont vos positions on va le voir
s'afficher après ce premier tour de
table avec quels sont vos positions à
vous sur le sujet votre mouvement a
soutenu emmanuel macron notamment
pendant la présidentielle je le rappelle
vos priorités par exemple disait chômage
par deux c'est bien mais ce qui serait
bien c'est qu'il n'y ait plus de chômage
qu'on soit en situation de plein emploi
parce que l'emploi c'est comme
l'alimentation au logement ce sont des
droits fondamentaux pour pouvoir vivre
dans la société normalement donc
effectivement il faut libérer le travail
libère le travail l'accès au travail
parce que on un pays créatifs ont un
pays dynamique en appeler à une jeunesse
qui est pour beaucoup sont au chômage
donc on a on a plein de choses à faire
pour avoir du travail
donc les solutions là dedans
effectivement ce sont de favoriser
l'accès au travail mais également de
protéger l'emploi parce que laure
l'emploi si si je parle de l'art delà de
la loi robert hue de 2001 qui était
abrogée tout de suite tiendront à votre
parti voilà exactement du mouvement des
progressistes qui visait à empêcher les
lanceurs des licenciements dans les
grandes dans les entreprises qui faisait
des bénéfices
donc ça là dessus il faut véritablement
également empêché ce ce genre d'action
est par contre les entreprises qui sont
faillite
là effectivement j'ai plutôt les
positions de la démo ni cyril henri pour
l'alliance royale sur votre site
internet à vous aussi vous n'abordez pas
directement cette question cette
problématique de l'emploi et du chômage
qu'en est il est ce que ça veut dire que
vous n'avez pas de position sur ce sujet
l'avant une position mais là encore il
faut remonter d'un cran on peut
promettre tout ce qu'on veut
on peut dire faire de parler de mesures
de fait j'ai vidé en mesure est je veux
pas je veux pas dénigrer ce qui vient
d'être dit il ya un cadre et ce cadre ne
permet pas aux entreprises françaises de
créer des emplois ça je crois qu'il
fallait
monsieur hollande a promis tout ce qu'il
voulait monsieur macro va le faire il ne
renverseront pas la courbe du chômage
parce que ça n'est pas possible à moins
de remettre à plat un certain nombre de
choses à l'équation à moins de remettre
à plat un certain nombre de choses et
notamment une concurrence équilibré
entre le marché européen dans son
ensemble et les marchés concurrents
parce qu'en plus ce n'est pas une
législation française qui résoudra le
problème mais c'est au niveau européen
qu'il faut le discuter donc là vraiment
je pense qu'il faut qu'on sorte là aussi
du cadre et qu'on arrête d'arriver avec
des petites mesurettes je dis pas qu'il
ya pas des choses à faire au niveau
français au niveau fiscal au niveau de
la concurrence favoriser effectivement
les petites entreprises et toute
l'activité de proximité ça a été dit
dans débats précédents mais il faut
aussi commencer par remettre en cause la
liberté de circulation des capitaux et
des marchandises qui font que un produit
chinois qui arrive en france avec une
législation environnementale qui n'a
rien à voir social qui n'a rien à voir
une monnaie sous-évaluée
il sera toujours plus compétitif c'est
la cause du problème jean christophe
christophe pélissier excusez-moi
christophe pélissier le parti
animalistes non plus n'a pas de position
tout cas sur son site internet sur ce
sujet là qu'en est il pour vous en effet
en fait le partenaire liste est imparti
monothématique donc il ne se positionne
qu'en fonction de la question animale de
façon directe ou indirecte
donc il n'ya pas de positionnement par
rapport
ce sujet là par contre ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que le parti analyse
soit développer la filière de
l'agriculture végétal et un objectif de
réduction de 25 % de la consommation du
produit des animaux d'ici 2025 de 25%
donc c'est ça sera bon pour les animaux
puisque faut savoir qu'en france on tue
à peu près un milliard d'animaux thérèse
parents ça sera également bon pour
l'environnement puisque l'élevage
industriel représente après 15 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
plus que les transports
enfin ça sera bon pour la santé
puisqu'il a été maintenant prouver qu'il
ya un lien évident entre des maladies
cardiovasculaires et la consommation de
viande donc en fait le parti animalistes
souhaite vraiment développer cette
filière de les cultures végétales non
plus ça peut être local en cumulant les
circuits courts
donc voilà c'est sur cet aspect là qui
réduit puisque on parle d'économie
imaginons par exemple on sait qu'il ya
des trafics d'animaux importants qui
permettent à des gens de s'enrichir
est-ce que ça aussi c'est une position
soit bien sûr tout à fait c'est une
position du parti animalistes que
d'interdire le trafic d'animaux donc pas
de pas d'enrichissement sur la vente
d'animaux également bien sûr interdire
tout commerce importations une
production de fourrure
toutes ces mesures là sont son parti
animalistes gens disent à youssou vous
concluez ce premier tour de table sur
cette thématique de l'emploi
votre mouvement souhaite être en phase
avec les aspirations des citoyens c'est
ce qui est inscrit sur vaud affiche
alors quels sont les souhaits des
citoyens
je pense que les switch et des citoyens
se sont
ce sont les mêmes sur à peu près tous
les sujets quoi c'est de retrouver de la
sérénité alors si l'on parle de l'emploi
je voudrais faire peut-être premier
liminaire donc c'est m'associe à tous
les constats qui ont été faits sur la
surréglementation que l'on a en france
et qui pour moi est une entrave évidente
à l'emploi j'étais avec un agriculteur
tout récemment et qui faisait remarquer
à juste titre d'ailleurs que les 400000
normes et des règlements que l'on a en
france découle souvent d'une surenchère
et que fait l'administration française
sur ce qui a envoyé deux de l'europe
on fait donc l'europe n'est pas le mot
deuxième chose que voudrait faire là
c'est une manière du constat c'est que
cette réglementation européenne que l'on
critique ailleurs et 200 m ne pas poser
de problème
si en france et pose des problèmes il
faudrait quand même qu'on se pose la
question de savoir pourquoi ça pose des
problèmes en france et pas ailleurs en
allemagne et en suisse avant et c'est le
troisième remarque je voudrais je
voudrais faire c'est la suivante dont là
c'est du vécu
il se trouve que j'ai voulu moi dans un
secteur d'activité au titre de mes
différentes fonctions où le taux de
chômage est de 4 et demi pour cent ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas de problème
d'emploi et au contraire c'est si un
problème d'emploi c'est le taux d'emploi
qui pose problème et non pas le taux de
chômage
clairement il manque 10 messieurs
numérique 1 donc il manque 10 mille
10000e gens qualifiés par an dans ce
dans ce secteur-là
et puis toutes les questions sociales
qui se posent sont abordés d'une manière
totalement différente que ce que l'on
est en train d'entendre parler on
parlait des travailleurs détachés voyez
moi j'aurais cru au travers de mes
fonctions des gens qui viennent
d'afrique subsaharienne ou d'afrique du
nord trouvent de l'emploi tout de suite
y'a pas de problème
désolé messieurs si vous êtes un peu en
avance on va voir les temps de parole
s'afficher mais vous semblez porter une
position qu'il fait peut-être référence
à certaines qui s'opposent à certaines
d'entre vous c'est ce que certains
souhaitent peut-être de réagir ce qui
vient d'être être être dit cyril henri
oui il y à un chiffre des chiffres très
intéressants qui sont sortis sur
l'emploi industriel en europe c'est la
tribune qui avec a publié sa yahia il ya
quelques semaines
l'emploi industriel depuis 1995 donc un
petit peu avant l'euro mais ça prend en
compte toutes les mesures européennes
il a baissé en gros de 25 à 28% dans
toute l'europe et il a baissé dans tous
les pays dire que même l'allemagne qu'on
prétend être un champion a vu son emploi
industriel baissé de quelque chose
comment entre 15 et 20% et pour la
france c'est un tiers donc c'est
catastrophique
donc il faut réellement faire des choses
au niveau de ce cadre européen qui n'est
pas le bon cadre alors on voit on va
voir les temps s'est figé pour voir
certains ont beaucoup de beaucoup de
retard pas mal de retard sur d'autres
candidats on va les voir s'afficher dans
quelques instants si possible sinon je
sais que voilà on voit le temps sa fiche
et christophe michel du retard axel
bruni du retard est ce que l'un des deux
souhaitent réagir peut-être poursuivre
axel brunet allait il pouvoir l'europe
c'est une chance l'ouverture des
frontières c'est une chance vers les
marchés pour les entreprises c'est une
chance également ce mieux se connaître
entre européens c'est une chance et pour
ce qui concerne les travailleurs
détachés et c'est augmenter la crds et
un smic européen permettrait de résoudre
pas mal de choses et également
comment dire l'europe il faut passer
cette europe monétariste dans laquelle
on est aujourd'hui pour passer
véritablement à une europe sociale et
qu'on avance tous en même temps et qu'on
crée véritablement un même à même
engouement pour l'europe et j'espère
qu'il est en train de revenir sur le
devant de la scène
on va passer à la deuxième thématique de
cette émission puisqu'on a un petit peu
de temps les transports c'est un sujet
très large très vaste les problématiques
sont nombreux sur les transports en
commun la route aussi la pollution
là aussi quel message vous souhaitez
porter à l'assemblée nationale si vous y
allez le 18 juin
on va commencer même si je m'échine que
là aussi vous n'avez pas de position
formelle avec christophe pélissier alors
moi j'ai imaginé une position est ce que
vous êtes par exemple opposé à la
création d'infrastructures qui
empiéterait des espaces où vivre des
animaux je connais la réponse mais ça
avait fait une liste de réflexion il
faut respecter au niveau de
l'aménagement du territoire la faune
bien sûr je vais parler aussi du
transport des animaux parce qu'on n'en
parle pas mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
forcément de réglementations précises
sur le transport des animaux il ya des
mots qui sont transportés pendant
plusieurs jours sans boire et sans
manger
donc en fait le party animal y souhaite
mettre en place une limitation de voyage
de huit heures pour les animaux
terrestres et de quatre heures pour les
oiseaux gilles pour le voit
sur les transports non pas sur les
animaux aussi de réagir sur les animaux
gilles pour le voit sur sur les
transports quel serait votre priorité
avant par exemple il ya un aspect les
transports c'est que il faut essayer de
limiter quand on peut donc il ya la fois
pour les usagers le développement du
télétravail peut diminuer le transport
des usagers de la civilité ou du social
si l'on veut avec le covoiturage ou ce
genre de choses rapprocher des gens
limiter le nombre de véhicules en
circulation c'est aussi des bonnes idées
c'est pas des lois c'est juste des
incitations que l'on pourrait émettre le
circuit court dans le cadre de
l'agriculture
en général pour alimenter les rêves les
magasins où les usines c'est aussi des
idées pour diminuer le nombre de camions
en circulation la l'utilisation plus
importante des rivières des canaux en
déshérence ou
dans quel circuit fusion non développés
c'est aussi un chant qui peut aussi
amener du travail de l'emploi à travers
ses travaux et on peut dire qu'il ya
aussi un problème du désengagement de la
sncf sur un certain nombre de lignes qui
est assez pénalisants pour les
populations centre-france campagne en
général là aussi à la fois du confort
pour les usagers télé du travail pour ce
qu'il est un met très en état ou des
blocs ces six mois
cyril henri pour l'alliance royale alors
on est dans un cadre très formelle avec
des sujets très très habituel quelle est
votre position à mesure sur les
transports
alors là c'est une position personnelle
je crois que là aussi il faut il faut
remonter de d'un niveau la problématique
des transports c'est la problématique de
l'aménagement du territoire notion qui a
été complètement abandonné par l'état
depuis - au moins vingt ou trente ans et
actuellement on assiste à une vide les
provinces pour remplir la l'île de
france et ont construit et on construit
et en bétonne est embêté own donc là je
crois qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faut complètement remettre à plat
dès qu on densifie dès qu'on concentre
la population on multiplie les problèmes
et notamment les problèmes de transport
donc je crois qu'il faut arriver à un
modèle économique beaucoup plus
équilibrée qui celui qu'on voit en
italie ou en allemagne ou même en
espagne où il y à une multitude de
villes moyennes de taille à peu près
comparable qui sont pas et tout ne se
concentre pas dans la capitale donc là
je crois qu'il ya vraiment un enjeu est
le deuxième point qui me semble
important qui est un peu en marque par
rapport aux transports
mais quand même je je je crois qu'on
gaspille énormément de terres agricoles
de très bonne qualité notamment dans
tout les périphéries des villes où on
devrait faire des de l'activité
maraîchère et c est un problème et c'est
d'ailleurs sur le territoire avec cette
fameuse ligne 18 du grand paris 1,5
seulement voilà je crois que là il ya
une ressource à gérer pour l'avenir pour
nos enfants et elle n'est pas gérée
donc on devrait savoir quelles sont les
bonnes terres qu'elles sont les terres
moins fertiles et en fonction ça on
devrait organiser l'implantation des
habitations et des industries j'en dis
ça y est je crois savoir que vous avez
plutôt une tendance écologiste votre
point de vue sur sur les transports
assez rapidement puisque vous aviez dit
que j'ai en tête en fête a été évoqué
d'ores et déjà moi je pense que les
transports c'est un moyen sûr hein quoi
ce qu'il faut penser c est la finalité
de transport et donc moi je suis pour
qu'on améliore tout ce qui a trait aux
besoins en déplacements qu'on soit très
très clairs sur la notion de besoins en
déplacements et qu'on s'organise autour
de ça et les besoins en déplacements
quelque part ils vont prendre une toute
autre tournure dans une société qui est
de plus en plus tertiaires s'enliser
avec le développement du numérique et ce
genre de choses dont des centres de
télétravail le télétravail à la mise en
scène de télétravail ce sont des
infrastructures qui pourrait compenser
sur une vision moyen long terme ce qui
est le sens de l'engagement politique
que de nous devons tous savoir qui
devrait compenser les besoins en 2d fera
structures de transport voilà et pour
information puisqu'on parlait de la
ligne plus la ligne 18 mois je me posais
aline 18 ans qu'on n'entame pas des
choses de ce genre là céline julier pour
ciel j'ai pu voir sur votre site
internet que vous étiez favorable à la
préservation des terroirs et paysages
ça peut avoir un lien avec les
transports oui alors je suis d'abord une
petite parenthèse je suis chanceuse
monsieur et à ce titre je sais pas si
les gens connaissent très bien les
chasseurs en précise les chasseurs sont
des gens qui aiment les animaux et qui
contribue à la préservation de la nature
helmand vous savez que une population de
sangliers double en une année si on ne
fait rien donc ça fait partie vraiment
de l'écosystème et ce sont les chasseurs
qui indemnise les agriculteurs quand il
ya des des gains de grand gibier
parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait leur travail
c'est une parenthèse donc j'aime les
animaux et je les connais assez bien
on ne veut qu'on le tue pas en général
non mais ça c'est un autre débat mais
réellement s'il y avait pas de chasseur
vous auriez beaucoup de dégâts dans les
cultures donc si vous voulez c'est
l'équilibré l'écosystème en fait c'est
la chaîne alimentaire qu'il faut
incriminer un moment là je reviens sur
les transports j'ai déjà développé ça
puisque je me suis présenté en tant que
tête de liste aux régionales
or les transports font partie de la
compétence du de la région donc je ne
reviendrai pas là-dessus l'aberration du
grand paris express etc
je viens sur un point précis sur les
transports qui va beaucoup parler au
parisien
je suis contre le droit de grève
illimitée tel qu'aujourd'hui le
pratiquent la cgt les transports on a
encore vu ce soir hier et avant-hier
avec les grèves je trouve ça scandaleux
ça me ça m'irrite énormément parce que
pour moi c'est antidémocratique ce sont
les les organisations syndicales
aujourd'hui mettent en coupe réglée
toute l'économie
ils font ce qu'ils veulent la pluie le
beau temps tout ça pour des
revendications très personnelle de
salaires de retraités
je suis contre ça je reviens sur ce qui
gêne beaucoup les français c'est pas
tellement le problème des transports
je reviens sur sur la pelouse en restant
pour vous aussi désirable à une question
il aura la carte blanche
alors je garde ça pour la carte blanche
mais voilà pour les transports travaux
indique a aujourd'hui tout va bien ils
miseraient donner la parole monsieur
brunet je vais en profiter puisque vous
êtes un peu en retard sur le temps de
parole sur sur la chasse on va pas
lancer un débat mais ça vous permet
peut-être de d'exposer un peu plus vos
points de vue pour le parti animalistes
oui bien sûr la chasse en fait nous on
est déjà pour interdire la chasse de
loisirs c'est complètement absurde de
dire qu'on aime les animaux et de les
tuer pour des fins de plaisir de loisirs
donc on veut interdire aussi la chasse
le mercredi et le dimanche
interdire toutes les formes de chasse
les plus cruels la chasse à la glu ce
genre de chose le tout ce qui est piégé
parce que quand elle met des pièges dans
la forêt il s'est pas sélectif n'importe
quel animal peut se prendre dedans donc
allé à tout un tas de mesures par
rapport à la chasse aux pour participer
animalistes que vous pouvez retrouver
sur le site internet et bien entendu je
pense que quand on aime les animaux on
peut pas dire on aime la chasse on aime
les animaux c'est juste pas possible
axel brunet c'est pas la thématique de
la chasse excusez moi ce sens c'était
pour vous redonner la parole
axel brunet vous êtes un petit peu en
retard on verra en sept ans j'étais
d'accord sur certaines choses sur le
pourquoi se déplacer
pourquoi le télétravail aujourd'hui
n'est pas mieux acceptée en france ça va
prendre toute la technologie pour
travailler de chez soi et souvent d'être
beaucoup plus efficace que d'aller au
bureau et en plus de perdre mon temps de
travail dans les transports cuisine à
caen paris se transforme en grand un
grand tapis de voiture il ya mais aussi
facteur la voiture la moto c'est un
plaisir alors selon les transports
collectifs c'est ça peut être un
supplice souvent savait pas mal arriver
on peut arriver le soir quatre heures
après être partie de son travail alors
qu'on n'habite qu'à 80 km surtout avec
la température actuelle
oui senti mes compagnes et donc
effectivement là dessus le temps de
travail peut résoudre certaines choses
et je me suis jetée pas forcément
d'accord je pense plutôt que la
concentration de population limite les
rythme pendulaire les transports
pendulaires et permettent aux gens de se
dépasser
quand j'étais parisiens pendant dix ans
j'ai eu une voiture je me dépasser en
vélo et riant métro donc est la dernière
chose c'était que effectivement il sur
les transports il faut revoir les
transports actifs les améliorer et
surtout baisser les prix que ça ne
devienne pas une charge parce que tout
le monde a le droit de pouvoir se
dépasser facilement
moi j'ai aujourd'hui pour pour dépasser
par avec la sncf c'est un budget à
dessinant et les transports dans les
zones urbaines devraient être beaucoup
moins cher alors on a déjà dépassé les
30 minutes d'émission il vous reste
quand même votre carte blanche on va
voir aussi votre temps de parole
sa fiche est très rapidement je vous
rappel la carte blanche vous pouvez
mettre en avant le thème que vous
souhaitez aussi en fonction de votre
temps de parole qu'on va voir s'afficher
à l'écran voilà donc christophe
pélissier évidemment vous aurez un peu
plus de temps sinon c'est plutôt
équitable pour les autres pour les
autres temps de parole donc on commence
avec vous christophe pélissier vous avez
plus d'une minute j'ai envie de dire
pour pour exposer la thématique que vous
souhaitez la thématique savez je
l'expliqué un petit peu les différentes
mesures du parti animalistes non
vraiment il ya la création d'un
ministère de la protection animale pour
renforcer tout l'arsenal législatif pour
protéger les animaux augmenter les
peines encourues
lorsqu'il ya des sévices et de la
cruauté envers les animaux enseigner le
respect des animaux à l'école on va
introduire sa dans le programme scolaire
des enfants faciliter l'admission des
animaux de compagnie dans les maisons de
retraite et les foyers d'hébergement
puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
abolir la corrida bien sûr interdire la
production le commerce et l'importation
de la fourrure
mettre fin aux pratiques de chasse les
plus cruels donc désolé interdire
également la pratique du gavage demandé
à ce qu'il y ait un repas végétal
alternatif dans les cantines dont toute
la restauration que l'étude manière
générale va donc toutes ces mesures là
en faveur des animaux qu'on peut
retrouver sur patins animalistes ce que
je veux dire aussi c'est que les parts
et amélie style indie droite gauche il
est indépendant et c'est un vote de
terre détermination utile pour montrer
que la question animale n'est pas un
sujet secondaire
donc c'est important de voter
massivement pour partie animalistes pour
montrer qu un électorat qui est sensible
à ce sujet là j'envie sayous selon votre
carte blanche à vous vous avez beaucoup
moins de temps de parole que christophe
puissiez vous avez le temps peut-être
d'exposer un point de vue une thématique
voilà donc le thématique centrale sur
laquelle je m'engage en fait c'est une
démocratie citoyenne alors une
démocratie citoyenne c'est quoi et bien
c'est en premier lieu comme en suisse en
dernier recours c'est le citoyen qui
décide et non pas je ne sais trop quelle
tentative d'assemblage de partisans dont
les citoyens sont en mesure de capter
les enjeux sur la plupart des débats
référendum d'initiative populaire
votation et c'est nous mêmes et de leurs
effets c'est pas le référendum à la
française la réforme à la suisse si ça
n'a rien à voir et je suis contre le
référendum à la française est justement
complet ensuite la deuxième chose c'est
le faire en sorte que nos instances
délibérantes aille vers
des fonctionnement basé sur le compromis
le compromis du plus grand nombre dont
là dessus il ya des tas de mesures a
derrière ça pour arriver à cette chose
là
la troisième chose c'est que les
citoyens décident lorsqu'on les appelle
sur un scrutin qu'ils expriment ce
qu'ils pensent et non pas qu'il soit
invité à éliminer voilà et céline julier
vous avez aussi votre carte blanche à
les plaisirs voici - temps de parole
déclare très rapidement alors le premier
point pour moi c'est l'école je pense
qu'il faut il faut enrichir et enrichir
les programmes à l'école pour pouvoir
proposer quelque chose qui parle aux
enfants qui d'abord les nourrices parce
qu'ils ont envie de savoir des choses et
puis qui ensuite construisent en eux
l'amour du pays
l'envié est aussi l'effort parce que
quand vous mettez un certain niveau
atteint les bains c'est le sens de
l'effort qui est entraînée comme un
muscle et je pense que c'est la
génération de demain qui est dont il est
question il est important de créer des
citoyens demain qu'ils aient envie non
pas d'être finalement subventionné de
recevoir des allocations d'être à la
charge la société mais il faut
construire reconstruire quelque chose de
finalement plus sain moralement le sens
de l'effort pour nos enfants le goût
d'apprendre le goût de réussir le goût
de se prendre en main et de pet
le deuxième point c'est sur la justice
et ça c'est très important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à un
rétrécissement de la possibilité de
l'expression par ces drôles de
l'expression le la possibilité de
s'exprimer librement et drôle vous êtes
aujourd'hui plus condamné pénalement
quand tu pars pour des propos que vous
avez tenus que pour avoir par exemple
des trous c'est une petite vieille et
l'avoir laissé pour mort donc ça c'est
très important et il ya une chose
importante c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans les
médias il ya de plus en plus de lettre
d' excuses de gens qui se sont exprimés
librement et qu'ils ont obligé ensuite
faire un mea culpa en faisant pub ou en
publiant une lettre en disant je n'ai
pas voulu dire ça et ça ça me dit on
voulait seulement parler on risque aussi
d'avoir des lettres qui vont arriver
dans la boîte aux lettres de la
rédaction axel brunet vous avez un peu
plus de temps
le débat citoyen ça m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment très
intéressant
j'ai un électeur loupé maintenant ce
sont des choses effectivement que nous
défendons également au sein du logement
des progressistes et à ma droite
éthiquement l'éducation va forcément
l'éducation c'est quelque chose de très
important quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui
avec internet on a libéré une parole qui
dit tout et n'importe quoi ou une
information très importante doit tenir
dans un tweet ou un texte tellement
petit qu'il ne veut rien dire c'est une
caricature et aujourd'hui on oublie ce
que c'est que l'éducation qui est de
développer l'esprit critique s'informer
de lire des livres et de pouvoir se
faire sa propre idée sur le monde qui
nous entoure
et tant qu'on restera dans cette société
du bashing du court termisme et
émotionnel et bien on ne prendra pas le
recul pour construire une vie est une
vie meilleure pour tout le monde et sur
le long terme
donc c'est vraiment très important
effectivement l'éducation qu'elle soit
au centre des préoccupations de nos
enfants mais également après après le
bac de continuer de se former toute sa
vie et de toujours être attirés vers
vers l'éducation parce que sans ça on
devient il faut bien comprendre qu'on
devient esclave esclaves de la parole
unique
vous avez parfaitement récupéré votre
retard séries l'an votre tour vous avez
un peu moins de temps à leur carte
blanche évidemment sur la question des
institutions
c'est une question clé nous avons vécu
pendant les neuf derniers mois les
primaires puis les élections
présidentielles les primaires ou des
visées les camps les élections
présidentielles ont divisé le pays
nous avons un problème le chef de l'état
ne représente pas les français il n'est
pas un arbitre parce que comme il est et
il est tiré d'un parti il ne peut pas
jouer ce rôle d'arbitré il a des comptes
à rendre à ceux qui lui ont donné le
pouvoir
nous avons un vrai problème
d'institutions qu'il faut qu'il faut
traiter nous avons aussi un problème que
système des partis qui confisque
l'ensemble du système
il faut donc vraiment corriger ça oui je
suis royaliste mais je vous expliquerai
après je vous employez ajouté mais c'est
que je n'ai pas de bulletins de vote
dans l'est dans les bureaux de vote et
qu'il faut aller le télécharger sur le
site de l'alliance royale sur internet
il nous restera peu de temps m après
qu'on fait à l'antenne on termine avec
vous gilles pour le voit et puis
rapidement
bref moi je suis plutôt sur l'après
élection déjà mère en amenant un
argument pour les électeurs pour qu'ils
votent puisque les voix qu'ils vont
porter sur les différents candidats vont
avoir un effet sur ce qui va se passer
cet été
les parties ont explosé ça se décompose
ça va donc se composer et je pense que
les lois qui auront obtenu pendant ces
initiatives vont jouer sur la façon dont
cela va se passer
merci je suis sur le futur merci à vos
six pour votre venue en plateau merci à
vous aussi de nous avoir suivis pour ce
débat sur la 2e circonscription des
yvelines
la semaine prochaine les débats se
poursuivront sur notre antenne et
notamment pour la 3e circonscription la
10e la 11e et la 12e bonne soir à toute
bonne soirée à tous et merci à tous et à
toutes
[Musique]